[Music]
you just showed up like you might need
some practice
you going down for the count it's going
down tonight i do it all for my family
you do it all for the likes i hit that
bell and i'm ready to fight turn me up
turn me up turn me up they want the belt
they don't work and know don't mess
around
yeah what is happening it is calabasas
fight companion ufc 276 the boys are
here we're missing one we get to that
but to my left is the very funny the
very talented thank you i'm eating steak
right now you are you are you are deep
throwing that brisket oh hold on yeah
i'm not mad at it dude
you're starting only fans to do that but
this is uh trevor wallace you guys know
my man hell yeah crushing it crushing
all over it and then directly across
from me is the mma royalty josh thompson
one half of the podcast weighing in with
big john and i wish big john was here i
missed big john yeah we like to get him
over here too we got to get him over
here one i know we have a bellator show
in l.a maybe we try to link it up
because we're going to give him that one
time then the flight was like nine grand
it's so ridiculous why is that like yeah
he finds out an office was like 3 200
bucks yeah he was like i'm down no no it
and then the seat that is open here that
is the
i would say the most handsome fighter
that's why i have them across from me i
don't want and i'm not saying you're not
handsome but i didn't want him directly
next to me because i look like
it looks like childhood buff and peanut
butter falcon yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's a handsome bastard he is
makes it worse he's like six three he's
just ripped and shredded so he's got a
small [ __ ] for sure you can't have all
those assets
because they're always good
he's blessed with everything both you
guys got cauliflower here i'm jealous
yeah well you can make it happen yeah do
you okay give us some time i got a
question when i used to skate back in
the day i wasn't as good as my friend so
i'd take my shoes and i'd rough it
against the skateboard to make it look
like i'd skate are there guys in the mma
community that like punch their ears at
home to make not smart ones
that's the ones that are good because
it's like a badge of honor you know
what's interesting is in brazil because
you know
third world country the uh jiu jitsu is
really expensive so it's like uh how is
fighting people expensive well judicial
it's free
spell yeah
yeah the glasses are expensive so in
brazil like the in the favelas kids will
take uh pliers and phone books and do it
to the ears because it means like you
have money if you do it that's that's
what i'm saying is like is that like a
sign of respect yeah yeah people won't
like fight you at a bar if they see that
no sometimes you get some you get some
stupid people in there yeah you know
they're drunk whatever yeah it is kind
of a test the liquid dude when i first
came to la i uh auditioned for this huge
show on e it was like my breakup
kardashians i j i wish yeah i was gonna
be like yeah it was gonna be [ __ ]
kobe kardashian's
no um for bbl
no i
i just for a show i got it we shot the
pilot i just retired from ufc i'm like
bro i'm going sizzler tinseltown here we
go yeah yeah four months go by i'm
calling my agent like low level agent
every day every day every day finally
four months go by he goes bro i got good
news and bad news i'm like hit me with
it he's all bad news is they're not
picking up the show like what the [ __ ]
he goes hold on good news though you
ever seen botched i know yeah he goes
those doctors want to fix your hairs oh
wow
would they pay though ah dude
they're just gonna do the procedure for
free but i was like oh and i was part of
me was like that'd be cool to have
smooth airs again but then it's such a
bad honor like no no the mma community
be like oh you're voted off the island
but everything i've ever read everything
i've ever read there's like a five
percent chance you could actually lose
your ear because as they're scraping out
all the the cartilage and the well it's
all dry it's all dried up blood
basically what it is it hurts so bad
yeah
so what it is they basically just peel
back the skin they cut around the edge
they pull back the skin and they start
scraping it off but they scrape away too
much because it's connected to the
cartilage the the blood that's all dried
up in there if they scribble it too much
you can end up losing your ear oh bro i
had a surgery on this one it's my worst
one it looked like tortellini i had a
surgery during my ufc career so how do
airpods work with that they do they
don't they don't oh that's what's kind
of tight
this this year works fine this year is
no no yeah
if i was at a bar i'd wear like beats by
dre like over my ear then if somebody
tried to square up i'd be like what's up
dude then pop the fight over
yeah no that's why people make fun of me
because i always have though though the
wired old school apple ipads because the
small the wireless ones won't fit like
oh dude i thought you had money you
still use the wires yeah like that's my
[ __ ] ears man yep and you don't want
to lose them anywhere they'll pop out
when you're running you gotta chase them
around on the ground you're stepping and
kicking them i've had i had tried a
couple pairs where they well the pro
version would actually go into your ear
yeah and so i'm running and then it pops
out and as i pop out i kick it and it
goes along and runs into the dirty ones
work and this isn't just because they
sponsored a bunch of my shows before but
the the raycons
ray jay's thing yeah i've never heard of
it
it comes with a dick too oh yeah it
comes with a lot of stuff yeah big black
dick yeah free video that we've all seen
before
wow it's so funny on the recon ads they
say like what to say what not to say
they're like don't say anything about
kim k please no don't mention the kim k
video but it's like it's hard to
reference ray j without being like you
know you know
you know the guy the guy that one guy
with a louisville slugger between his
friends
you know
yeah the guy that made kim k's career
yeah but but what else where else you
gonna go with it like you you might know
him from love and hip hop yeah oh you
might know him as
was it maui
what's his sister's name chin
yeah brandon i said malisha that was his
sister's brandy yeah
i didn't know randy killed a guy ran him
over
what got away with it when
i mean like [ __ ] six years ago really
yeah
wow wow that just ran him over how she
run him like
drinking
i don't know there you go fatal car
crash in california r b singer brandy
38 year old woman yeah oh he's in a land
rover yeah
oh it was on my birthday december 30th
okay on the 405 wow
on the 405. how the [ __ ] was somebody
walking on the 405. you know it was they
were in the car
and it hit a small honda oh that's not
good i take back everything i've said
yeah brandi did no time nothing wow on
the 405 yeah dude i'm surprised if
you're ever going over 30 miles an hour
on that freeway i know
well it's not too bad now depends what
that
wow well
what's your monthly on spotify
can i ask you a question what does it
take for rogan to pull out a tie really
like it's like this must be a really
special event for him to actually have a
time i mean he's not don't get me wrong
this is a stacked ufc card but it's not
the biggest he's ever worked you know
what he's at a different level well i
went when i was promoting my special i
went out there and did a show with him
and there was like security everywhere
and he's like yeah how you doing i'm
like good good and as the night winding
down you know we did our show we're
walking back and i go bro you're like
hanging out with a politician now yeah
like it's like there's no more like just
oh let's go to the bar go everything's
like
calculated i was like oh yeah
yeah they're just in suits there was
there was like steps right like so chuck
and i chocolatel and i were real good
friends then he started making his run
tattoo no no that's brock
go around like you just it was like you
know what i'll meet you back in your
room we'll have a drink you go out i'll
see you
next time like that because i still go
to restaurants he's the exact same just
the
who was it trevor noah said it best he
was like
some people aren't made for
the the entire population like there's
niches and then one he's been rogan's
never changed and then once you get to a
certain level of fame then the general
public's like wait who is this guy and
they look into it like oh my god i'm
offended it's like well yeah it's not
for you he was doing it for his audience
that's how i feel about videos it
reaches my bubble and then the second
like one layer outside of that that like
the people who [ __ ] with you that one
layout that's what people like what the
[ __ ] this is comedy now yeah what
happened to the good old days like the
three scrooges
i don't even know from the 50s yeah yeah
i mean but but that's what it is well
i'll tell you what's not from the 50s is
manscapes fellas manscaped it's not from
the 50. product alert
if you ask for it and they definitely
listen to the bros out there my friends
at manscape just brought back the
ultimate smooth patch talking about how
the guys 14 on the left
it's time to stop drop and order this
premium shaving kit everyone knows by
now that the lawnmower 4.0 is the best
electric shaver ever for your nuts but
if you're looking for a closer
listen you got to get down there the
ultra smooth package is the perfect set
it's time to shave that bush of yours
and get right to the roots with a
discount just for you guys talking about
your [ __ ] yes talking about that big
dick ray j style get 20 off free
shipping at manscape.com with code cfc
we got you guys covered man the ultra
smooth package three step kit to make
your package
perfect man whatever you want we got the
crop exfoliator crop gel it's time to
shave you know the 4.0 is the way to go
again get 20 off and free shipping with
code cfc at manscape.com that's 20 free
shipping with code cfc manscape.com
smooth out your fellas with the relaunch
ultra smooth package from the fellas of
manscape your balls will thank you
you actually really get a reading
contrary to what people say about you i
know that was good i know i flub lines
all the time me too
i do 30 of them a week so my reading's
getting better
as you're reading it and you're doing
well and then all of a sudden chin just
moves the [ __ ] words in the paragraph
you're like and then you're live switch
the promo code you can't find the end
tag where they're fighting tonight is
that where rogan was at last night yeah
that's got to be insane those are just
two nights of work for him same place
same venue same office ballin balling so
just yeah that's how much he's born
so when you know uh he had to sit out
when the when the ufc's when all the
canceled close [ __ ] was going on bro who
filled in for him uh michael bisping
who's phenomenal okay but you know it's
joe rogan yeah yeah you're gonna take
[ __ ] for filling for joe rogan but um he
did a great job but um
dude he loses money working for the ufc
yeah really if he if so let's say this
guard so if he did a night in arena
instead of doing this card he makes more
money doing stand-up comedy oh 100 he's
just doing it because he likes to do it
oh yeah
so when they're like you're suspended
he's like say less
i said two or more i'm gonna do this
arena at the honda center and make all
the money oh please don't that's crazy
oh dude just different level he does it
because he loves it like you said like
you said he doesn't change no change so
this is him like he does it because he
loves it
he's been part of this sport since
you know forever
but it's like he's making his he's he
just wants to keep the routine he wants
to pick and choose which fights he wants
to cover don't you think this is weird
josh is in this for you too trevor don't
you think this is weird name another
league where
two guys who don't fight are more famous
than anybody in that arena on any given
night so there's nobody more famous than
you see than joe rogan dana white
they don't compete oh there's the yeah
because they're at every vet right they
their careers are so much longer they're
just bigger personalities dana white's
obviously the president that faced the
ufc joe rogan's joe rogers it feels like
they're the kings like back in the day
the colosseum days like they're up
they're just calling the shots
right well i mean like you could say
like the wwe right but like who else you
want in there like obama just posted it
i don't know like who else i'm just
saying but name in another league like i
felt like roger goodell's not as famous
as
holmes no
no but you really you still how you oh
they didn't play or didn't ever fought
before yeah that's what that's what i'm
saying
and i have no problem it joe's one of my
favorite people on the planet i'm just
saying and dana deserves it it's just
different and like vince mcmahon owns
the w he's out now right yeah is he
oopsies i don't follow oh oh yeah i
don't follow it either but yeah he got
he had some trouble my producer podcast
dave is going to be it breaks his heart
every time i say that he's a big wwe
like not hugger yeah
yeah he had some trouble he had to step
down i think his uh daughter's stepping
in for it stephanie mcmahon
um yeah and some dicey stuff
but uh
but vince mcmahon also
he wrestles like he put himself as like
the main event during wrestlemania and
[ __ ] you imagine if dana was like make
yourself the main event yeah dana was
like
it's me versus whatever uh but mark
cuban main event over izzy and freaking
well
the fight that never happened that could
have potentially happened was the boxing
match between tito and dana i think
remember there was that beef back there
fourth and like five weird though right
yeah i think it'd be really weird yeah
you're fighting your boss what do you
think's gonna happen after that anyways
and any yeah those are the things you
lose to your boss
i mean let's be real dude
tito would beat the [ __ ] out of them
that's the first fight you know i think
i don't think so
have you ever seen data files i've never
seen native fighters
buddy come on yeah you know dana did
cardo kickboxing classes for a while
this is correct maybe he's maybe he's
got good boxing shape
come on doug
uh the first fighter which i love the
first fight is uh uh i'm sorry the first
fight is brian barbarina and robbie
lawler and what weight is that that is
that welterweight right is there eight
it should be a seven should be a seventy
uh no lightest would be one twenty five
whoa one twenty five yeah but they can
still whoop my ass yeah that's the thing
there's but they're tiny so it's tough
dude because i think like the general
public like oh they're too small they
can't beat me up so they don't respect
them so nobody really tunes into it but
like the bigger dudes everyone's like
yeah they're bad someone tuned into that
but it's like hey don't get twisted the
150 pound girl would whoop your ass oh
dude those
and if it looks like we're sweating in
here we are because they forgot to turn
our ac and calabasas is 115 degrees
so let's lose some weight fellas yeah
it's deep steeped this studio is deep
deep i thought you were like lying but
yeah calabasas
studio city it is in the heart
dude
you don't come out here what do you got
you got no i passed through my parents
are like if you just keep going down the
freeway
no my parents are like they're like
ventura county oh wait one on one so i
always drive past give their asses go
ahead and give your parents oh my
parents had dressed
seven two two yeah how did you know that
yeah what were you gonna say jeff
so i got o'malley finishing finishing
the fight finished by knockout uh
against pedro he's never been finished
how quick though you think first round
are these newer is this a type is it
five or three so the
first the last two fights the main event
komen event or title fight so every
title fights five rounds anything not
title fight or main event is three
rounds three you guys watch a lot
growing up
uh with my buddy cj we watched all this
but that was like anderson silva brock
lesnar day shout out to cj see dude yeah
we'd go over to his dad's house he'd
barbecue you know what's cj doing now
mushrooms
i swear to god
no dude he's a great guy but he's like
up in like washington i grew up with my
best friend but he's super into
mushrooms now is that where he grew up
no no he just somehow moved out there
now you're from here uh yeah yeah the
same area like ventura county but we
grew up there together and then he he
he's just one of those guys every time
you check in yeah but he was never like
that he was always like he lived in like
arizona was very like money oriented ran
his own companies this and that and then
i think he's one of those guys he's like
money currency doesn't matter anymore
those are my favorite guys and then he's
like i actually sold everything that's
now liquid
and my currency is vibes and you're like
right but landlords
how do you
but he's a great guy but he put me on to
like watching all these fights growing
up and uh yeah we'd always watch him at
his dad's house and you're like right
vibes uh have you seen the gas prices
lately
yeah i mean it doesn't bother me bro but
yeah man sometimes you gotta just give
in to the shrooms you know ah man god
bless them i wish i saw that
i wish i was like that i don't remember
insane amount of guys that would fight
back then but well we're doing the names
we were doing a uh
a show at the laugh factor i was like
dude dude do the companion can you know
i don't know if you've ever seen trevor
do stamp monster
we do a bunch of shows together [ __ ]
i'm so talented
and uh you have that comedy look to you
thank you dude no don't take that i know
that's good no i
irvine july 22nd through the 23rd
hawaii july 29th
yeah jeez
are you really at irvine oh i met her
you think i came on here not plug my
toilet plug it on july 22nd through the
23rd trevor comedy.com get you some man
yeah get in there dude daddy's in fort
wayne july 14th to the 16th i don't know
you've been to fort wayne i am not it's
a new club the owners i love they don't
like uh
bricktown oh you're talking about that
yeah they run a lot of great they're the
best yeah they've never stirred me wrong
they're oklahoma one's great one of my
favorites but they're like hey how do
you feel about fort wayne indiana i'm
like absolutely not and they're like no
no i'm telling you man this is a great
car yeah john fish lives there that's
where he's oh he does he's there right
now for two weeks what's up john come on
out yeah he's there for zero it sounds
like a legit city fort wayne i've never
i don't think i've been to indiana i
don't think so never indianapolis or
helium out there i did go there once
yeah yeah you're right when is that uh
july 14th through 16th then right now
plug it plug it in boy.com that's making
olivier
she's made my boy joey benavidez take it
easy trevor but um
san diego laugh factory is july 21st to
23rd did you do uh because i did uh i
always do uh la jolla
san diego live character is insane i
love it dude it's perfect you do shows
when did shows there no no
i just had my own weekend i've never
heard of it and then i did it and i was
like holy [ __ ] this club is rocking it's
insane in omaha right now right
no uh he would he might no that's next
week i think town was in new york for
something else got it wait why is uh
first oh and when brian barbarina is
like first second the biggest wow this
isn't the biggest fight it's a big oh
there's so there's five big fights on
this car so are they doing this just to
hook people because people at buffalo
wild wings aren't drunk yet to watch
this
you're right that's why they that's why
they stack the prelims usually
yeah i used to watch fights at buffalo
wild wings it was a disaster yeah but
they're talking about tv they're in the
parking lot yeah yeah yeah so they're
just doing this up front just to like
hook people well
you still this is still pay-per-view
it's pay-per-view
so usually the first fight is is a
really talented like he's a prospect
right like this is his first like big
big fight is that fair to say he's a
pretty big sean he's a pretty
not as far as like credentials like he
hasn't beat anybody ranked no no he
hasn't but this is a big step up in
competition for him but i think the
speed of his reach
can you pull up with his reaches they're
talking to the other yeah
he's probably a little bit faster than
pedro oh you got the reach for sure he's
got the reach with the kicks and the
hands it's his footwork that's going to
be a problem not only he's a great
fighter pedro's got good kicks he's got
a little bit of wrestling you've got
good kicks
yeah the kick's going to be good as long
as he doesn't get caught into that chest
he'll be surprised though by uh sugar's
jujitsu he's no problem he's good he's
not good he's not pedro i don't think
he's going to take him down though i
think peter's going to try to beat him
the way that cheat to beat him with leg
kicks
it's not time so there it is so o'malley
inside the distance plus 130 o'malley to
win by decision plus 150
munoz inside distance plus one's
475. that's not a terrible bet no i went
yeah but i'm going i mean sugar's my dad
have you worked with sugar at all trevor
no i know he's in with like all the milk
guys and all that yeah i'm surprised you
haven't just because i don't know no i
haven't crossed paths with him but
that's what i was saying is like he's
the biggest guy i think right now in mma
just based on his like social
he's he's the he has like the uh the
kind of he's got that factor you know
he's got like the social he's got he's a
and he makes more money uh not fighting
than he does fighting
he makes more money off like twitch but
he's like a johnny manziel guy where he
like goes out and he's partying hitting
the [ __ ] like he's out at clubs he's a
wild boy he lives in arizona does he
really though what do you mean i i i
think i think not all i think he has
perception of that but i don't think i
don't think he's out there doing that i
think he's out there socializing being
part of the group i don't think he's i
don't think he's getting after again
after it though really maybe i'll take
some videos of that boy again
i know sugar pretty well i believe wow
no but i'm saying we can all have those
one night so you have one night a month
right you don't cut loose but i think if
for him to be as active as he has been
but he also gets better i mean he's he's
i don't think he's like he's constantly
working honestly i don't i don't think
he's like john belushi but i think he's
like you know but he also cares about
the social [ __ ] he's doing a bunch of
people's podcasts he's out with the
right people so he's like building a
name that way even if he doesn't do
another fight today he can still live
off like we said brand deals or just his
name there's really only two guys who
are kind of leading the way doing that
because there's a guy named patty pimlet
do you know him i do not so patty is
they call him the fifth beatle he's from
liverpool he's new he's only had like
two fights in ufc but
he's making more money fighting outside
the ufc
and and then he's he took a pay cut
signing with ufc because you're such a
big deal over in liverpool yeah yeah but
that dude's social media like we had on
my food truck diaries he's my favorite
of all time yeah but i was like because
he gets really big so he's like so he
fights at 55 right but he was probably
like 220 when he did food truck so
imagine 220 pounds he has to cut to 155
pounds i go dude
they call you take like a short nose
fight and he started laughing he was
like i'm not taking a short notice fight
i make too much money not fighting look
at him look at him that's him that's him
oh i do know this guy when he's not
fighting i know him now can you show a
picture of him when he is fighting he
might dude he might have the best
personality in the ufc who's the guy
that theo had on on his podcast and he
was in overalls yes
uh that is mitchell uh
he's great can that dude [ __ ] people up
and grapple his uh
he's strong he can wrestle and he's got
good grappling history the reason i [ __ ]
with him not that i agree with all his
political points but he just he's not
worried about the backlash i got him on
a shop show and he you know he's going
nuts about gun control and corona and
all this stuff i was like my god dude
what is that we got dragonflies on the
suit
have you seen the video of bruce buffer
doing a breakup for somebody on cameo
somebody know cameo paid him like five
hundred dollars to be like yes kaylee
it's time
to move
it's one of the best videos you'll ever
see out here he makes so much money
doing cameo he was trying to talk me in
the door i'm like that's just not my
thing i'm good i don't need to do more
[ __ ] he's like you know how much i make
i was like yeah but you're when they put
me in
there
and it's time to drop the cask in the
ground it's over yeah
yeah bruce buffer he's in a legend
selling yeah cameo hit up john they
still got iron start doing it boy
we're like yeah no we're good uh herb
dean herbert being here for sure
is the age silent or do you say is it
herb or herb no it's herb it's herb herb
is it herb or herb damn all i've ever
heard is herb herb
i've never heard
a bunch of icp fans this is this is
vegas right yes sir this is a great
fight dude so kick it off with this
yeah he's got to be careful just not
chasing after him to try to make up that
that range pedro has uh the i think the
the power advantage yeah for sure if he
was able to land there's no doubt if he
gets hold of his neck i don't give [ __ ]
how good sugar is on the ground it's
over if you told your neck savage he's
gonna have to get him down quite a bit i
mean you see the size difference in
height i mean and he's also not like his
wrestling isn't like
dc's or rockholds his wrestling's more
like jiu jitsu trips and you know he's
not shooting into a single chain
wrestling who's projected to win
uh sugar yeah but it's weird because
sugar hasn't fought like a ranked guy so
this is his uh first like big like kind
of step towards oh really they're
fighting big dogs they're going out it's
the perfect matchup they're going after
the fact that pedro's coming off of you
know i think he's won one in his last
four years how were those women go back
and pause it
of the first round guys look how much
bigger sugar is where's jake paul 455
right i don't know if they well they'd
let jake paul in for sure
just for the views because logan signed
someone with wwe right yeah loganstein
with wwb and then
crazy people the uh the the the bellator
girl did too
oh uh villa
valerie loretta lorena chin right to the
right
i had her up earlier you walk in we walk
in there's just booty all over the
valley
what does bantam weight mean 135 135
that's how much sean mice he's huge he's
tall though
he's so big tall long and lanky
and and he's kind of there's valerie and
she there's rather shoes get punched in
the face and that's your sister wwe oh
wow don't be mad at that trevor
hey don't be mad dude
welcome to fight companion she fights
she got some power for for being she's
[ __ ] tough for small all the verified
dudes in the comments yo fire emoji
relax
yes
give it to the dms fire girl so proud of
you
i love
paris inspo that's vegas god damn it
that's a comment they would say oh i
also love paris you're right
uk chen you could take a quick little
trying to watch this goddamn fight jen
and you can't do sound because
monetization yeah they'd shut us down
pretty hard and i knew their trust down
because even when i used to fight
company with rogan he was like we can't
have sound they'll shut us down i'm like
yeah but
you're you're like to face the ufc's
again no they threatened right all right
well we're sure it's hell not doing
sound it's a business
yeah to the fullest yeah is there
royalties off these fights if they like
read arizona absolutely not no
yeah it's tough man but sugar shawn he's
interesting because he doesn't have a
manager and he negotiates really own
contract he's smart he flew to vegas to
negotiate his own contract smart wow
when he was on food drive i talked about
i'm like dude i would get all your
analytics from twitch social media show
him your reach and be like what's this
worth nobody doesn't know his contract
thing though not not oh not a lot of
other fighters have that ability to pull
up like you said the analytics that's
what i'm saying that's why he's an
outlier like if you're going there make
sure you have your [ __ ] together because
i'm telling you man they're sharks
that's 10 20 whatever your percentage is
to your manager you don't have to pay
yeah you know that's a lot of money when
you start racking up the bills just
depends like sometimes you know you got
to be pretty thick skinned because
they'll hurt your feelings that's what
they're meant to do though you got to
know that you just got to understand
that look they're going to tell me yeah
but you haven't done this this and this
yet and just swallow it and be like you
know what i get it but guess what i'm
going to do this this and this were you
in on some of those calls josh yeah okay
i heard you heard you were in on one joe
silly i broke my heart i was like oh oh
oh this is awful no no my man was like i
told your ass i had some conversations
with joe silva about uh rumble johnson
because rumble and i were i was kind of
the one that kind of got him into the
ufc back when he first got in timeout
i love when they start booing for the
eye poke oh people get mad when you get
kicked in the nuts and you take your
five minutes oh boo come on get in right
yeah [ __ ] your nuts
she gotta ignore that stuff oh there's a
slow see this
i poke
uh
oh no no no no no no no no
unless it's skim the front you gotta see
it from this angle skip the front oh
yeah
yeah so when you see it from that first
angle you can't really tell when you see
it from the side angle you can see it
tipped the front of the good call refs
didn't mean to call you out it's more
yeah
yeah if it hits the tip that's going to
burn you know but sure if you need five
minutes but shoney though shony car
needs to wear the bigger cup for a bunch
of reasons oh yeah if i got to your back
like you just use it as a weapon
or no use it as a way you have to wear
it he's like then it was also easier for
you to like kick me in the nuts yeah so
then if i had if i felt like i was
getting tired kick me there i could get
a break tight move yeah yeah those guys
use those steel tie cups whereas we got
an arm bar that thing is that's all i
ever wore i never wore a plastic cup
like the taiwanese like a thong through
your ass crack it's all right man i'd
rather take that instead of getting i i
fought kid yamamoto kicked him in the
nuts broke his cup he couldn't continue
oh wow really yeah so it was like after
after i saw what happened with him i
never ever wore a plastic i never wore
the same cup twice i always got my cup
from dick's sporting goods like just
your nat like pee-wee football cup
and uh my first ufc fight jon jones
forgot his cup and we shared a copy oh
wow you're you're a savage bro that was
that's worse than being an eskimo
pretty big package no no no his his dick
was like gonzo's nose in the ski mask it
was just like wrapped around like a
sausage in a small bun so it's just mine
like like i said we were all just tied
up in there it was embarrassing he's
like this really fits i'm like just use
it
the leg kicks are kind of throwing shawn
off a little bit he just has to get his
time down he's so much longer man
what do you think about this whole ooh
what do you think about the whole uh
jake paul nadea stuff going on i think
dana wants it dan was like yeah you
should probably do that then let him go
let him do it that's what i said because
what's the hold up but did you see
because uh did you hear um dan hardy was
like you know the disrespect from dana
you know uh throwing shade at nate i'm
like i don't and don't get me wrong if
he throws shade i i always you know i'll
go other
he was just like man let's be honest
like he's won one i was last six not
like we're talking about camaro yeah
he's like so it's tough to find him the
perfect fight we're not trying the
problem the problem is though is that
people hate when you start throwing out
facts the stats are showing that he
hasn't won he's won one in his last five
like he said yeah like you can't do
anything about it like i'm not hating on
him no it's true yeah it's pretty black
and white i didn't feel like it was hate
i feel like just like we're trying man
we can't toss him in the title fight
makes no sense now one out of six yeah
and i i i still think that they're
trying to find a way to keep him that's
what this dream is all they're dragging
out is for conor to get healthy because
they're not going to let them go without
that trilogy fight they shouldn't
they're not going to that's all i don't
know why people can't figure this out
that's all they're doing they should
they're just waiting for him for connor
be like yeah my legs better i've been on
a boat doing whatever yeah let's do it
and then they'll let them sail off and
fight nate it's so funny because i see
all these other fighters trying to pitch
they're trying to shoot their shot to
get that connor fight you know like it
ain't going to happen
it ain't happening they're waiting for
what you think figure it out otherwise
they'd give nade a fight yeah conor
needs to hurry up can you make the
weight i mean i guess you can make 70.
right seven they fight at seven yeah
yeah seventy dollars nay's not making 55
anymore he don't want it he's not even
trying connor ernie 55 maybe if he gave
conor a title shot 55 against
oliveira but i don't think that's smart
for connor it's either nate or tony
ferguson yeah i could see oliveira and
connor fight to be honest i could see
him fighting terrible idea but not even
for a title though i get to see them
fighting
because charles has all the power right
now so you know i don't want the title
right now i'll fight conor that's a
bigger money fight if it's not for the
titles it doesn't matter connor's still
a draw if i'm a connor fan like dude we
gotta get you a win here you can't i
agree because it's over you come back
and lose again it's over let's go tony
ferguson which is an easy fight but
still winnable nate diaz not an easy
fight still winnable you're not fighting
the tip of the spirit yeah but let's
let's not forget that that second part
of that whole that conversation's not
even ufc based it's boxing mayweather is
already offering 150 million conor to
fight a second time that's so stupid
it's a horrible fight for for conor but
150 million trevor did you watch uh
conor versus uh floyd uh did they get
your money
uh i think my buddy was live streaming
it like through illegally streaming oh
yeah yeah yeah one of the guys got it on
a macbook pro you know
plugged into it
yeah [ __ ] i'm 14.
how about i illegally stream this from
my mom's basement yeah like we got to
get to that the whoever's doing this or
when restaurants charge oh
restaurants will charge you to get in to
watch it but they forget that they have
windows outside so people just stand
outside and watch it a lot of bars will
do that move yeah i'll tell you what i
had a buddy owns a gym he was like oh
ufc won't know i'll just say it's for uh
private use and i'll put the ufc on bro
they caught him literally within hours
yeah it's like hey [ __ ] we looked up
the address oh jim you have multiple
people in there we're going to come
after you for 75 billion so do they they
charge more if you're like a restaurant
or established
based off your capacity yeah it's based
off based off your capacity so like that
so if you're like buffalo wild wings or
you're you know whatever they'll pay you
off your capacity so your capacity is
180 they base it off of that they don't
even care if 180 people come it's based
on your videos
yeah that's what my boy had at the gym
put on a big projector and he's like all
right well that can hold about 200 i
think i think how many people did you
say that's about watching this today
would you say when you bought this how
many people did you say were watching it
i'd say there's probably about 700 000 i
think oh no in this studio right now oh
oh oh i don't know just does three i
don't know
you know yeah you're trying to justify
this dude i'm wearing a wire you're
[ __ ] dude there he
hell
is
you just got a lot sex here in here hey
yo my boy's in shape too you look good
man trevor
i just gave you a little finger luck
there it is
he's handsome
distracting
heard you got lost on your run dude i
lost the running take the mushrooms and
the mushrooms just tell you where to
like how far to run yeah
you know you find inspiration out on the
road and just keep going
you're never gonna get hate here for
being late for training man when they
told me to run i'm like hell yeah i was
like yeah that was good yeah
there's some there's some uh food damn
chicken and there's chickens don't worry
you saw it cole i got my my girls oh
she's got scaffolding she's got me like
dialed in and she's like yeah she has an
iv with just freaking she's got
everything ready yeah she takes all
these great dog since that's how i've
seen you you're in [ __ ] shape you're
not messing around no i'm here to
[ __ ] win
yeah i love it dude where's your fight
coming up i'm gonna kill us i know you
are i am uh your fight in september uh
it is uh august 20th august 20th
yeah he kept pushing him back i think
he's getting like veneers or some [ __ ]
obviously that's a cool reason to push
back i need to be hot i don't know i
heard her there's a real one fight could
get because you're getting like hair
plugs or something yeah something he's a
handsome
it was this it was supposed to be
tonight originally they wanted it for
international fight week and then they
pushed it back to to
the 30th in dallas
and then finally he pushed it back
because there's some other
cosmetic thing i guess hey can we just
say like cosmetics dude you guys are
fighting for the best looking dude in
the ufc both you are [ __ ] gorgeous
dude yeah one of them only has
credentials to say he's a real model huh
i mean technically very important yeah i
mean
to say he's a role model he's like fire
you up just looking at him like i'm
gonna beat his ass how you doing oh you
got poked again there's your meal luke
see that yeah
look at look at this [ __ ] model look
at dude
it's a battle of looks yeah
you're winning though dude right now
you're winning just gotta win the fight
if that photo just
here's the thing if you take that right
he looks sure he looks he looks built
but if his dude takes his shirt off this
guy's [ __ ] shredded veins from his
[ __ ] abs up to his [ __ ] chest oh
dude if that was my thing i'm jacking
off to both of them oh yeah say that
right now trevor
[ __ ]
that's a great fight though luke i
didn't think it was going to happen to
be honest a great fight
i'm excited about we had your building
as a perfect fight it was absolutely
perfect fight to come back to and
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill them yeah
straight up yeah so
from an eye poke no way whatever oh
that's what was it i almost said that's
game but that's not how this works
you know it's a bummer as i was just
talking about like jacking off to luke
and then i missed the entire time
let's see god damn it
what you got there
beets we got um yeah chicken chicken
beets chicken and broccoli
vegetables
perfecting athletes so i work cole like
manages everything for me and cooks like
a gangster so she works with perfecting
athletes and they just every meal is
prepped and ready man it's different too
is this what happened here let's watch
um we tried to backhand him oh no that
wasn't
that's [ __ ] holding him on the play
what are we talking about
so they award him the win no i don't
think so oh that got him no it didn't
though
why would sugar
celebrate like you won i don't know
damn that wasn't really an eye poke
though
but why sugar dancing like that if
that's a cause because you got a
paycheck dude what are you talking about
they didn't have to finish the fight and
they're both getting better yeah but he
probably because he can't continue from
an eyeball though how do you how do you
guess well
that means that shawn loses anyone half
head
can you hear me what's happening
there's no way put on the minions movie
but the worst part is is that like
they're if they're on show if they're
like on that show and win bonus yeah
they're only gonna get their show money
both yeah yeah that's kind of they won't
be a win that's kind of their contest
right towards uh you can't hear it huh
casey can you hear it how far along in
the fight is it um the second round
that's the second round yeah yeah so is
it definitely they don't touch like they
weren't even fun
they were just feeling each other out
there's nothing there's nothing happened
the whole time juno was laying a few
light kicks there was nothing official
decision so that means that they went
longer than i think two and a half
minutes or two and a half they went more
than half the second round yeah so sean
if sean won the first round yeah you'd
have to give to sugar based off you
would think
well if they do it based off damage the
other guy can't see let's say you have a
peanut allergy wait
it's a draw right they can't order no
because if it's past uh whether it's i
think this whole sport is rigged right
anyone who says no oh no contest
what is happening what a nightmare this
is so weird all right take two this is
the hardest part of not being able to
hear it but yeah this is a trip
there he is steve will do it
running for president 2024
interesting
i just saw the thing with uh what are
they doing what are their cities coming
out like you're gonna come out what are
those what are they all doing there
where are these boys
why are they
why are they such a thing like
dana needs a chill little just review
dana needs to chill a little bit and
like let this look like a bunch of it
she's in business with them i know i
mean these kids can't be involved like
this this is this is the ufc well i
think you know they're really famous
just has him kate side but he's also in
business with him you know i mean come
on let's keep this let's keep structure
the business here let's not get too
fanny yeah boy
come on boy uh so what happened
what is no what happened no content yeah
so there's no they can the fights
basically what is it what is press
actually wrestling rainbow learning yeah
just high school wrestling high school
yeah
he's teasing all right something like
that
yeah high school wrestling are you
trying so how does that go down on the
record is that the middle point was like
just a note so it wasn't even a draw or
nothing so they're going to have to redo
it there's nothing worse than no
decision especially like that fight
people are so hyped for it oh yeah not
the way you want to kick off the paper
but i'll tell you what this next fight
is i think they should have this as the
first one to get people crunk for it
robbie lawler you say crunk crunk dude
okay from 19 making sure we're still in
2004 memphis
what was nellie's thing called what was
his squad called oh oh what was it they
the guy had a band-aid on one band-aid
the banana 100
man
big pun in the terror squad what was
ah i'm a st lunatic wow
old school dude
so if people bet on that fight with with
sean how's that money back god that's it
yeah disappointing yeah yeah oh and if
it's in your parlay like my draftkings
parlay
it fricks ya yup it's all [ __ ]
everything up should we fight
i mean i guess dude i don't really want
it what is the last time you knock
somebody out legally
i mean
i can tell you really i mean legally it
doesn't have to be legal it's it's cool
it's better
i can't put a legal statement on forever
i've never really been outside either
these two more like unified than me
these two handsome bastards
josh
josh's fights
josh puts it down like he gets a little
you know there's a little fire when i
was there's a fire so small
fire but i'll tell you what like josh
would
ride with you to the end if you're
surrounded by by a gang of fools josh
will be there for you
and he'll take a beating
you're the like but he he likes to spark
it yeah he definitely likes your
marketing if you had a problem you got
to be worried about somebody nudges
one of the most famous stories i guess
you could say it was like we were all in
miami for ufc 42 and it was like all
this [ __ ] 42 ufc 40 jesus christ yeah so
we're all there for ufc 42.
and um
sherdog was there sean sean uh shelby
wasn't even working really with the ufc
yet and
he was just like he just started we were
all out and then uh we got in this big
ass scrap that right down there on uh
the street of south speech yeah
so we start scrapping
and we the fight ends up boiling over
into a restaurant the guys are trying to
run and pull themselves in me and then
rich cronkite not him but his buddy
jimbo you remember jimbo so jimbo's just
like
this hillbilly guy with like a wife
beater on just comes out he's got long
nails you know she's about to hate me
can we just stop for a second and like
if that dude becomes champion that's the
weirdest thing get in there so i'm like
crystal freaking weird hippie guru dude
like like just he's two minutes he's too
far out there you think uh i think he's
too far out there
i think as he smokes him this is the
speed thing is what's going to be the
speed i mean
he's got a demon inside of him i mean
he's going to try to push but is he just
going to is he too he went from
heavyweight he's too precise 85 he's got
the mental strength to get through
whatever adversity he's got to deal with
that's a fine anything happen though you
know i mean and he throws really hard
he's been fighting for a while yeah
yeah
when you were watching back in the day
yeah i know the name yeah robbie lott
was your guy lawler and i both got
signed the same time to the ufc back in
2001
yeah he's been around for a long time i
remember watching him fight in one of
these small casinos i think it was up in
calusa
uh it was like i think it was gladiators
or it was king of the cage he walked in
he knocked out this guy named landon
showalter in like 19 seconds just
[ __ ]
stiffed savage
this is like the most i would say as far
as if you're looking for a straight
knockout this is it like they should
have kicked off the main card with this
yeah there's no way this goes decision
and if it does fight the night lola's a
[ __ ] animal dude this guy is
no punk either no no he's not but i'm
saying
[ __ ] me
too but i love barbarina but uh lawler's
a slow starter is not yeah barbarian
comes out like you're [ __ ] happy but
at the same time not look what he did
against nick diaz yeah lala came out
like a bat out of hell right off the bat
that's true you're gonna find guys
you've never seen yeah you're right you
gotta find guys that motivate you to do
that though
robbie's like you know he's a
spiritual being and so it's just some
fights he lets it go and sometimes he
gets in his head and he bottles it up
too much but he's with you right now
right at sanford right this is
a little bit i'm here for the most part
down and up and down up and down yeah
with root canal
is pirillo your main guy when i go out
there i went out there went out there
like last last week to go test myself
and
just spawn just does you know obviously
there's all the [ __ ] all the guys out
there and sparring and
wrestling like really really getting
immersed with everything you know just
maybe what are you doing out there
well i was i was working with that day
with
with jason jackson and camaro yeah mark
me and camaro were pretty much all all
monday
and we didn't even get together walk out
songs before i had a little little
injury just sent me back for the week
but it was it was a good test it was a
good test you know but you're getting
all the boys you're getting good ones
seeing
how i match up you know wrestling and
mixing it up everything's good i mean
you know everything's on track
dude you need to go out there to know
you can wrestle oh you're savage i feel
like you know you make sure your timing
and everything just up to par you know
with these kids and dude if you don't
sharpen if you don't implement your
world-class grappling in one of your
fights
i'm going to do nothing about it
but i'll get on here and criticize you
that's it that's about all i'm going to
do
i don't think people realize i think
it's the relaxation you know i wanna
forcing the issue and trying to get to
the ground is is when that's when you
get in trouble you get in trouble and
stupid and that's what i did with yon
and i just you know
i just gotta relax and let the fight
come to me because i can win anyway
anywhere this fight goes correct but
obviously there's an adventure they
still got stick
you might have to go for this
assuming you're coming out probably
because you're throwing the ground oh
yeah
[ __ ] yeah if i touch if he touches the
ground
the fight will be over in a minute
unless i agree i over over agree i will
just i will decimate them i know i wish
people knew that's something how good
you're [ __ ] grappling and i'm better
than i've ever been really i'm better
and stronger than i've ever [ __ ] been
i actually work yeah i'm excited for you
man
i'm excited just to test my [ __ ] body
because you i i you see you were you you
interviewed like i lost the fire a
little bit took some time off just going
through some [ __ ] and then look at you
now dude
the looks don't go though the looks
don't fade dude it's annoying
it's annoying how do you feel about guys
who danced too much getting to the
octagon
it depends who you are like izzy does
the same thing and then shows up now if
you dance like that and then you get
starts in the first round
fights that's hilarious for us
bad for him yeah yeah yeah no i love it
because it shows their relaxation that
means like when they get in depends or
they're not focused like when hamzad
fought uh gilbert burns
in the corner you're about to get
knocked out and he was on top of the
sitting out there what are you doing bro
you got a real trouble but he was trying
to try to traditional what you see just
terminated this has always been robbie
lawler though what were you were you
terminated or were you out here doing
the cash i was pretty high i was a
mixture i was pretty hyped what was your
walkout song uh square dance eminem
people
did they do you ever submit a song like
we can't do that i did when i was
fighting no guarant brazil i did chris
brown beautiful people for brazil
and dana called me that before i was
like hey that song is really gay and you
can't come out to that i was like oh say
less so i did square dance yeah
interesting i would have done take you
down by chris brown but you know
but you know that's just me
yeah sometimes the the kibosh your
walkout song man can you can you have
like a rapper in your entourage like
wrapping this didn't somebody do that
somebody came out with a rapper behind
them they've done it boxing boxing
boxing well yeah floyd came out with
justin bieber before box comes out with
bags
but bieber wasn't singing he was just
holding his belt
which was even weirder yeah so if you
can be in my corner dude you gotta sing
yeah i'm coming out with bill nye the
science guy i'm gonna give a [ __ ]
just to throw somebody out be like oh he
got science on it is that the science
guy on the belt oh he knows knowledge
he's like a hype man
that'd be sick yeah just to [ __ ] with
people's heads i'd walk out with elon
musk
do you think that guy walks that dude
floats dog not have him on like a dope
ass like robot tearing him to the
octagon oh yeah i'd walk out with a
fleshlight i was driving in south
florida there i saw a sign said it's
okay to say gay because gay is cool
right
in florida yeah
that's florida baby yeah florida
tournament is cool now so you can see it
you can drop it any way you want
yeah one of our kids it was
look at my lopez ready for the fights
thanks dana white theo got on this on
the prelims he got so mad at me because
he put dana white we don't deserve this
stat card hashtag ufc6 i just texted him
like dude this is so lame he was not
happy when i him that but he he always
you know stays super thirsty get on the
freaking thirsty the little pop-up yeah
everyone
oh my god
can i get on there oh easily dude
i'll plug my irvine text it right now be
like dana my god we don't deserve this
thank you see you in irvine whatever
you're dating irvine july 22nd 23rd yes
40.
daniel how old are you luke 37 how old
are you josh
40 i'll be 44.
damn getting older can you imagine
fighting right now 45 no no no
the four throws me off i don't like it i
feel like 40 is the new 30. i want to
get out no i want to go win this fight
be dizzy
whatever it takes you think you beat uh
well because the next the title shot
from my source is a pretty good dude uh
the winner of sean strickland pierre are
guaranteeing the next title shot yeah
let's see that i come in and i smoke
this dude and
everything will come bro you and sean
strickland talking [ __ ] would be
phenomenal
you ever think about that sean
strickland is a pain in the ass he
trained aruca though for a little bit
didn't he yeah yeah did you spy with him
i sparred one time now how'd it go
i would [ __ ] it was a close round way
too close oh yeah he i heard he said
everyone that's the thing like
i wasn't even i wasn't even
in to sparring at all that day i showed
up i showed up and i was just like so
i was just really [ __ ] hung actually
i was still drinking hungover
still doing my thing back then and that
i was just i missed that luke
yeah i was i think i always had black
eyes from like
some [ __ ] i had busted my nose up or
something long night
yeah and uh i saw this guy out
in the gym you just he just kept making
a commotion just one of those idiots
around the gym you know the guy just
like an [ __ ] just oblivious to
everybody and just a loud mouth and just
yeah really that's really annoying guy
that's me that's me and i was just like
and i was just like screw this i
couldn't take it anymore i was beating
up a couple kids so i was like i'm
putting my stuff on
and we just went to war yeah we went to
war we went at it we went at it pretty
good just [ __ ] him up one down
he's a savage he's just got weird timing
that's what i heard weird timing i
wasn't in shape but i wasn't ready for
anything he pushes the page pissed off
the scraps yeah it was and it was like
it was it was an even [ __ ] hard round
yeah uh we had more but that was what
that was that was that's hungover luke
yeah we had marvin victoria in here and
i was like who do you think wins
strickland or pierre and he was like
strickland dude he was like you know
people want to say just this wild man
he's like he's pretty technical his
defense is really good like he's not
technically i gotta give him credit like
he was saying his defense like technic
like his defensive skills are really
good people are not really getting shoot
up too i mean he just hangs back over
the top so if he's like if you're like a
an orthodox fighter he gets cleaned with
overhand rights so if this guy this guy
comes over the top with a left body
overhand right watch mark my words that
could be the end of sean strickland
tonight because he's susceptible to it
every time you go left body overhand
right i'd be more worried about the leg
kicks with pierre for sean strickland
because he doesn't really work on him
i've watched this kid spar a lot and
he's just like he's he's so tall he's so
back on his back foot he's just here
he's here and he's he always leans out
and so if you take the body he comes and
he comes out who's paella
a lot strickland
i've watched this far a lot but but also
with strickland it's like if it's not an
ego thing it's like dude pierre has no
grappling dude yeah
it's so stupid it's so stupid like what
the ego did to think that this guy is
like i don't want i don't like sean at
all but to think this guy's put in this
position just to like get to the title
because he could have the two kickboxing
wins it's like i want to see sean wynn
me too at the same time but at the same
time i want to see him get knocked the
[ __ ] out
yeah i feel you come on these boys are
throwing them but i i i
obviously the universe for what's right
then this guy fresh meat for izzy this
guy's
you see him at the press conference he's
just like he just he had no idea what he
was doing where he was at what to do
he was like whatever
god these boys are swaying them i
appreciate it right now first last time
we saw a mohawk
van nuys tuesday
that totally makes sense
[ __ ]
yeah
just throw it right robbie's got to
throw 40 more
he just
there it is there it is oh come on
rubble is a little more technical he's
just tighter with his defense and he
puts his combinations in his power is
nasty i think barbarina came out with a
little bit more like let me throw a lot
of punches and see what happens yeah but
really he'll slow down as it goes on
robio robbie's robbie's getting his
timing you can see him he's just too
robbie's going to start getting him i i
feel like an upgrade
how's
not putting like uh some heat on some of
these at all yeah none of them you don't
want yeah not like levels that's not how
you want to be like he's just
pitter-pattering
over never like an upper level which
isn't the way to go with robbie oh
because robbie
takes four years to exchange one bomb
you gotta show him it's kind of like
rock and soccer right now that's why we
love it
i respect it
someone kill that dog for me i don't
know what's up what's up why is lucy
crying
oh is that your dog yeah oh oh it's not
a dog is it a pig
pig
what is it you got pigs out here
welcome calabasas doug also where the
[ __ ] you guys cooking steaks around here
we gotta grill out the back
is lucy
it's not a pig
oh it is a dog oh robbie's doing good oh
she just wants food
crazy eyes got those rihanna eyes
the dog goes everywhere with luke oh
yeah
it ran with you while you're on mushroom
that's the heat now yeah you got to keep
with it though because oh
what did i say about that uppercut son
i'll tell you the uppercut's there for
robbie come on it's there dude
robbie just got to just throw a little
bit more stresses me out
you know you know where cowboy retired
tonight yeah he lost got choked out by
jim miller but it's time though he's
gonna head off to try to do movies more
movies he's already doing movies someone
said he's getting busy though he said
he's real busy yeah he just did the gym
crushed in that gina chronicle which is
on bench network perfect look like
there's certain
like for him i feel like those type of
movies he's just
tailor-made for 100
does robbie cut his lip again oh my god
that was nice these boys are see see
trevor you see why i said kick the
pay-per-view off with this yo yeah right
body shot
they're supposed to be on the prelims
oh he's going he's throwing
that that one that one rocked him that
won't hurt robbie a little bit yeah
robbie
robbie came in he's a little different
robbie's face is like robbie's filipino
yeah yeah he has a splash of filipino no
yeah
yeah
i splash i mean half which is a lot it's
a it's a
this is great
that's a great feeling hell yeah
the vaseline in the cut does that stop
bleeding yeah yep
like they do like adrenaline first to
stop the bleeding and they plug it with
the vaseline
that's like the coolest thing i've ever
seen so it clogs up so the blood doesn't
run in your face and what's interesting
is you like in the middle of the fight
you can't feel it yeah you run out of
time
later that night in the hotel you're
like oh my god oh yeah i got ran over by
a train yeah it's awful when i fought
when i fought tony ferguson after i got
done with that fight i had to sleep
sitting up with a neck roll pillow
because i had so many cuts on my head
what though i had stitches and i had
lumps everywhere so i had to [ __ ]
sleep sitting up same thing with the
gilberlin as the second fight yeah so
when these dudes go out to celebrate
their win are they just deep down
hurting in pain yeah the alcohol though
kind of but you're still kind of riding
that high yeah you're writing that i
want to go out but then also i remember
after i beat crocodiles in the worst
pain in my life they're like oh let's go
like have chicken wings and i was like
sitting there like hazing my left yeah
and you're taking pictures with people
you're like just kill me yeah yeah
what was your record
uh
like 12 and
five yeah you fought a lot yeah trying
to go 12-6
no
that's why so dude i failed in comedy if
you see me doing a celebrity fight
against like mario lopez that means
business is not oh dude that would hit
bro yeah
i walk past the cage now like at the
bellator events i hear those guys
getting hit i'm like oh oh this is
adorable dude my son because he's in jiu
jitsu now so he's like you know dad you
they you fighting ufc kids were talking
about in school i'm like yeah i have to
show them like my highlights yeah i was
i'm like who is that guy yeah what the
[ __ ] were you doing yeah just like a
different mentality or just i have no
desire you don't remember
those years i know i remember like it
was yesterday it's just
i haven't watching for you crazy you
have to change it it's just you have to
reroute myself back in yeah
that was such a success so far out of it
for a minute so far off now i'm like
deep like in just rooted in it's it's a
different journey back into your
mentality
baby
so what's here i got one for you what's
the worst
like after a fight you know you come up
with all kinds of crazy injuries and you
go out you're still going to go party
yeah
what was the worst injury you said like
night going out after again crow cop
because uh he shattered my nose in like
70 different places still out drinking
and having you know cocaine
can't do coke and then
um hold on yeah hold up no yeah my nose
was shattered so i can't breathe through
my nose and then did
he was doing those bendy straws that go
through the throat come up through the
nostril
that after i lost the yawn i remember i
got sucked out there's so many people
and i think lawler's woman i had a
broken jaw after when jesus christ when
i was out of like [ __ ] every shot you
take just falls out of your mouth
there's a [ __ ] broken jaw i'm
bleeding out the mouth
and i remember making out with this girl
the girls are sad
how do you walk out with a bro i was
spitting blood all night like just crazy
like just she was like
i remember made out of this chick and i
was just
must have been just i bet she was
telling her friends she was like i've
never made out with a model before like
that's your chance yeah then i turn
around spit in the sink and just pure
blood jesus christ
she's like yummy
she don't think you get another shot
putting
urge to go out the urge to go out after
a fight you know like the temptations of
like oh you want to build up no matter
what happens you know that night
like you yeah like you still just had
the hottest it's still a celebration
it's like a release what do you do when
they call the guy like on the sean fire
you still going out oh yeah sean's party
tonight yeah if you had to fly he's
getting another tattoo on his neck or
some [ __ ] yeah
i think robbie's won in this round yeah
first oh oh oh he just took a big shot
though
he's gotta get back on the jab
are throwing the jab was working i don't
wanna
robbie could go five it'd be tough this
shit's heating up let's go this type of
fighting always like threw me off it's
like i want to be precise can we turn
the heat on in here
yes here's whoa
oh my robbie come on oh
my god all those all those elbows hurt
him he's going backwards come on robbie
robbie's hurt come on
come on
is just coming forward dude you guys
robbie already knocked him down a little
bit in this round oh elbows come on
barbarina's elbows are the difference
yeah i don't want to see rob making this
he deserves to be on his face come on i
don't know anybody that roots against
robbie lawler yeah
it's like he's at the end you know it's
like [ __ ] oh you got a roof i don't want
to see him go down no hell no i don't
see him
at least it's the fight of the night
he's still getting his 50 kills oh i
know you're getting in there come on
buddy do something wrong oh my god oh
god
oh he's hurt
it's over it's over stop the fight dude
god damn it damn damn jesus came out
dancing good fight though good fight
though your boy did put money in
barbarina i know that's very russian up
there yeah yeah but very russian of you
uh it's very russian to bet against
romney oh [ __ ] it's a great fight
there's not one second no
how you don't open up the paper with
that i have no clue that was correct but
thank god they completely redeemed
themselves because that no contest
really that's sorry [ __ ] the vibes
yeah can they just like doing like an
hour are you good you're good all right
so yeah is your eye better can we just
pick it up
you guys are coming so we'll start
hurts the most like a leg kick or elbow
all of them yeah they all hurt those are
not one of them
the worst is
it's basically a bat to your face i
remember that fight where silva broke
his leg oh no that was always the body
shin two
checks or so
yeah nothing like in a fight the pain
you feel from a chicken
like i can't that's like a pain you do
feel my leg broke my leg broke the first
kick when i fought you well that first
kick my [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah my shin
fractured
i could feel like i was like it hit me
so good i was just like
just
like uh and i kept kicking with it and i
felt the thing it was like blood on her
i felt like it was like vulnerable to
break and that's why i pulled back on
the kicks obviously it was [ __ ]
cracked right through the middle there's
certain fight there's certain things
that you just feel during the fight like
an elbow you don't feel like you know
like but the body kicks you feel right
you know yeah the cuts you don't feel
the [ __ ] the shin machine and the body
kicks you feel you or or yeah or body
shots you're just paralyzed there's
literally nothing to do nothing you can
do i'll tell you what else but there's
something you do about your pubes fellas
uh manscape product alert
yeah bro
you asked for it and they listen my
friends at manscape just brought back
the ultra smooth package time to stop
drop and order this premium shaving kit
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower
4.0 is the best electric shave for your
balls but if you're looking for a closer
save to go bear down there then the
ultra smooth package is the perfect set
it's time to shave that bush of yours
fellas get right to the roots luke with
a discount just for you get 20 off in
free shipping at manscape.com with the
code cfc
it's ultra smooth package it's
specialized groin shaving kit to help
you buff protect and smooth your most
sensitive areas like your nuts i'm
talking crop shaver razor
crop of foliator crop gel men you no
longer have to borrow your ladies razor
for that precise trim we got you covered
man grab your handy lawnmower 4.0 has a
flashlight so you can do it in the dark
which is kind of weird but you can do it
uh crop a foliater crop gel it's time to
shave we've got the crop shaver listen
man it's time to get up close and
personal with the best tools for the job
ultra smooth package from manscape get
20 off and free shipping with code cfc
at manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
smooth out your fellas with the relaunch
ultra smooth package from the fellas at
manscape your balls will thank you back
to the program
boom that was [ __ ] good thanks dude
great
public education
aurora colorado like colorado explains
education yeah because you definitely
didn't get it here in california no it's
dyson
dicey
he's a savage dude colorado's got
they've got one of the best education
programs yeah color's pretty good really
yeah yeah they're number two colorado is
good yeah public schools are good yeah
that's not a city yeah it is
yeah and also i mean
yeah they got really good schools here's
the crazy thing right now now after he's
wow
against
wow mustache looking that's my boy a
little she was good
shawn why the show was good flying
tomato
oh is he married to her isn't she the
girl from uh yeah with nina the diary oh
that's that's joe burrow and those other
two guys joe bro look at somebody
playing joe burrow yeah right that
doesn't look like him and dalia look at
his bucket hat i've been telling delay
about bucket hats for a hot second now
are you getting one i'm wearing one yeah
i got one i won one on supreme i never
wanted anything on there there's a radio
contest yeah it's like a raffle oh i
called into ktla and won a bucket hat
yeah oh no it's like a raffle on supreme
and your boy won is it sick i think it's
pretty lit i'm gonna wear it on kingdom
this thing
oh yeah i can't wait nobody will ever
roast you on that show
but i feel like a bucket hat
like my girl saw the problem the way
they did that when i was like dude it's
just about your face
pulled off the stage
there's a man who always is looking for
gloomy weather yeah he's just in the
rain all the time right he's in london
right now london
he went
delia got married so he went on his
honeymoon and of course he's such a
savage i was like are we going hawaii
fiji he's like uh london just this just
roomy downtown london because he just
drinks coffee and hangs out that's all
he does that's all he wants to do i was
like what about your wife she's like
yeah yeah yeah london doesn't seem like
a honeymoon though that's awesome he
could be like bora bora that's what i
told him like tahiti fiji he's like yeah
we're going to phoenix yeah right
yeah go to boston
i wonder how much the ufc took a cut off
this paycheck
for the video game yeah the video game
he's a big video game guy too no i know
i mean but the ufc taking a cut oh yeah
you know sure [ __ ] yeah but they
probably get as he gets like like oh you
wanna sponsor is he oh yeah
oh yeah we like video games i like we
want to sponsor the ufc and then we'll
give busy we'll take 80 percent and give
you like yeah 80 is generous 88 you're
not working we'll take 80
90.
we'll get content you know how does he
take any of your uh modeling contract
well no no no dan was like born like
that i was like no we were like in
dispute after i lost the title because
he was like [ __ ] you my contract was
[ __ ] and they were trying to put me
back to like some my
pay way before
i said [ __ ] you
he said we'll go model them i said okay
[ __ ] you i'll go modeled i became the
face of ralph lauren i had a [ __ ]
worldwide commercial
my face was an airport ralph lauren my
face in every airport around the [ __ ]
world and then dana white
and ufc came back to me and said luke
you have do you want this much money do
you want to fight this do you want to
fight there do you want to fight here
yeah because you got to know your will
if you don't know you're worth someone's
gonna tell you a word it's gonna be less
than your worth yeah the ufc tries to
[ __ ] you and we were just talking about
that if you don't leverage yourself back
right you know i was that was the
leverage that was that was the game it
was like but it was like it was like a
[ __ ] cat and mouse game was like
dan's like i'm like i'm deserve this and
he's like no you don't you deserve
something but that's the best
then i'll go do this yeah you have to
leverage your leverage leverage your
life leverage is all about yeah by luke
you have leverage most guys don't i mean
leverage i create my leverage i had
nothing i had nothing and i went in
there and [ __ ] i did well well you
had the looks
that got you something buddy
big dick bro i know
yeah you had leverage but then also does
ralph lauren did the the the right weber
bruce would ever want to suck my dick
and so he probably fought for me for the
ralph lauren campaign did ralph lauren
uh pay well was that a good deal for you
yeah i don't i don't know how modeling
works i don't know i made
over seven figures yeah jesus christ
seven and you're still fighting
dude if i get a couple mil off being hot
[ __ ] fighting i'm out yeah i'd start my
own ufc he's running out of
baskin-robbins you'll be broke real
quick
former world championships
what am i doing still trying to do
comedy how do i get hot
i know
but if you're not born with it because
if you just go to a doctor they can
smell it a mile away and they're not
going to hire you right you got to be
kind of born with it
you've had no work done yeah
they um
don't work done you got plumpers i wish
dude people think these lips are fake
but wrong
yeah
[ __ ]
what does the average fighter get per
round like for per fight this is another
whatever seal pays his features
does he not pay well no i'm just kidding
i don't know i've never featured for him
i'm sure he pays well but uh not great
as far as do you have so like what do
you think one of these
well that that's a main card on ufc but
like the prelims are like you got to
worry about like the so the average
income of that do you think either one
of them is getting i mean she might be
getting seven maybe amanda's making
money i'd be surprised if he either
they'd be like right around seven each
seven hundred grand no
yeah those are seven figures yeah
amanda amanda amanda
see i don't know sean's new contract i
think he got a flat rate of like 600. he
just signed a new one right yeah 600k
yeah per fight
uh yeah i'd do it
it's a tough one dude what did uh tim
what did it say the average uh
uh the average income of the us is 25
grand yet 90 percent of ufc's fighters
make less than that in
less than 25 grand in a year
or per file per fight i think people can
talk about these like these bonuses
honestly with the evaluation of the
company and everything growing like back
in the day when it was gsp versus
jake shields i believe they're doing a
hundred thousand dollar bonuses
and now there's there were there were
never they jumped they were a hundred
thousand five or seventy five i think it
was seventy three seventy five yeah it
was a hundred dollars you might be right
though there was a there was a time
there were a hundred thousand okay i
think they did it for certain fights
remember like oh this is this fight
stole the show it was like boom i'll
give you a hundred thousand more which
is the rest of the series he comes up
with this thing is like you know instead
of raising the bonuses they they come up
with another like crypto bonus thing
that we're giving out
little bill [ __ ] bonuses like two
grand five grand and ten grand just
dude it's like that the company has
grown
what
i mean since since the implementation of
the fifty thousand dollar bonus how far
has the company comes since then they
made the most
let's let's have the world talk about it
like if you want to make sure you want
to make your title shot dude what are
you trying to do here yeah you want to
make noise about it let me talk this
[ __ ]
i'm out dude imagine i need you
i just say what's real
yeah and there's there should be like
should easily be a hundred thousand
dollar bonus each oh i agree
i think i think they should be like can
you imagine if they were imagine how
much more
well how much more hype of the beast do
you remember when you were freaking out
of the night
for five five nights should be your
imagination imagine how much but you
remember when it was this thing would be
for everybody else talking about it it
was knockout it was submission
of the night and now it's at the
discretion it's performance but also
remember the thing about stuff too is
they do those like secret discretionary
bonuses
yeah
which you can't really calculate because
if he's not feeling a certain way you're
not getting those facts
i'm still getting paid i still get
checks in the mail for whatever it is
that they do for me so like what my
trading cards from tops i still get paid
from those [ __ ] my eas
i i get ea on top so we get paid for
that i just got to check the other day
it's not for much like 1200 bucks was
that ufc show where it was like reality
show uh ultimate fighter ultima were any
of you guys on that yeah you're talking
about season 10 the most watched season
of all time you were on how did you
brought that up oh my god yeah i was a
finalist really yeah
and i like the things because
kimbo slice was on there
that's right i'm glad you brought that
up trevor uh
you know trump played the big role and
now he's standing as a big part of that
yeah man that was great man yeah because
you know people thought you were his
brother you thought you were both
thought i was like
yeah he saw his son he's so shocked
in the shower bro he's all shot in the
shower he's like bro i thought you were
black that's the highlight of my career
oh he's just open with that truth
comedian coming to stage true story he
thought he was black
that's great that was a great time man
damn here we go i have a question does
strickland russell doesn't look like you
think he does i think he does too you
want to know why he trained with johnny
eblin for everyone's fighting
yeah
i talked to johnny before the father
dude i wish you had a couple more fights
not to say you're not ready right now
but just the experience
was too much too soon i thought too much
too soon he [ __ ] put it on gabe dude
there wasn't a moment that gary was
wondering didn't win a moment not once i
was so surprised i'm the biggest gay guy
dude when you i get gay guard the
nickname me and rogan did big dick
energy yeah that's why he like tries to
get bd bit bit of a chubby weight
we
right before um like on air because we
can't get away with it we can't get away
with big big energy so we call it bde on
we're talking about him on the top but
he's got a limitation because he doesn't
know like he's
he doesn't realize he's not that good
but he is that good
in his head he thinks he's the [ __ ]
man and he doesn't know actually he's
the man i actually don't think i don't
think he ever thought he was the man
that's why he goes up and down
just not he's not fasting he gets in his
own head he's definitely not fast enough
we just saw last week he's on the feet
but he's like
though yeah the motherfucker's good yeah
i think about the guys
he wins in bellator
bro he's got all his wins in the ufc
beat mark [ __ ] i know i'm in heavyweight
i'm talking about the lighting talking
about this i'm talking about that
i'm talking about this i get it but
we're still talking about light
heavyweight champ middleweight champ
he's good i'm talking about stopping
five in the world yeah i'm talking about
you don't think gay guys top five in the
world
not he's losing that guy i think johnny
johnny evelyn i mean everyone will get
into but johnny's not top five in the
world he still has a ways to grow yeah
you're right maybe once no
no but here's the thing i agree with you
on that but look i love you here's the
thing you know you know as well as i
know that guy's talking about guys
training together the guys talk guys
from the guys that they train with guys
from the ufc that's what i've heard
johnny was the real deal and i'm like oh
i i said yes he is the real deal i just
thought it was too much for him to bite
off johnny johnny edwin made me put my
[ __ ] foot in my mouth me too i was
like a hard worker
i think he'd come in what's can you can
you see what johnny evelyn is i think
he's got a two-time
division two national champ i think you
know i like i like his workouts do you
think uh johnny like a guy gets luke you
don't like uh skills you're gonna put me
on the spot right now with my boy no
i'm just but no
no here's a savage i agree about his
grappling striking but he wrestling wise
johnny's the better wrestler yeah
grappling wise he's the better grappler
that's what i'm saying yeah i agree with
you but he's got to get to the ground
offensively but he's defeat though on
the field
yeah yeah i agree with you i agree but
it's it's one of those
i'm just being
no
that's a tough fight luke's also faster
than than gay guard and that's i felt
like if you watched that fight that's
where that's where johnny edwin had the
the advantage john's just so much faster
started never like getting dropped
he wants to like get off and do his
thing if you just [ __ ] operate fast
he's just pot shot in that first round
pressure pressure
is a he's a sucker for pressure
i think he wrestles in the first i think
he wrestles to get the win because he
understands what the title shot's next
he does if he was smart you see one
versus jack herman he didn't even press
on the gas pedal when he had that thing
won
he's also a wild man so he might be safe
because he knew he was going to like get
that brush he also there might be a
thing where he hits an ego thing where
he's like because he in the in the press
conference he's like you guys you know
you think just because he's glory
kickboxing champions he can beat me it's
like well well yeah on the feet dude but
here's the thing here i think so i think
he's gonna fight some more i think he
realized he realized that he realized
that the last
third round and with the with that fight
the thing is it's better it's better for
the ufc if sean strickland wins i
disagree no
i think it better i think a better
pay-per-view dollar i get it but the
better
i agree i think though because you can
have you can show they'll buy the
highlights
strictly in the way he talks to you in
the press conference
i understand what you're saying but
they'll buy the highlight of him getting
knocked out is he being knocked out
they'll play that over and over and over
again by peja and they'll sell it
dude five in one fighting for if he went
this is a title right yeah
i don't think this guy looks that good
he's not good he's not good backing up
bro he looks like he's gonna fight that
kickboxing
doesn't look like precise but i heard he
[ __ ] he's got the [ __ ] crack i
heard he couldn't power he's pretty
crashed right he's [ __ ] in the gym
in the gym
three six four six
his knees are his big weapons because
he's just like he's just a beast
shaw can take a he can take a punch oh
yeah he hit himself good for him
he's a
you know you boys with them uh not boys
no no yeah not boy i don't know him that
well but he's just a beast
as far as like on the mic he's a savage
they just they need new people they need
they need new fighters
for
so the fact that both these guys are in
the top rankings now makes makes for a
conversation i think sean
who's the other guy
no one's not bringing no one he's not
and if you watched his last fight the
top ranking every time he got pushed
backwards he got hit with some big shots
and that doesn't transition all the time
so if sean can move him backwards sean
wins easy yeah moving back kicks and
knees
and sean wins pretty easy unless he gets
caught with something stupid
or not as long as he doesn't get caught
with something earlier
i think a knee on the inside those
elbows look at him talking [ __ ] to him
strickland's just a [ __ ] psycho dude
i really want strickland win this fight
he's coming forward
yeah he's got to get him moving
backwards because he but here fights
like uh pereira fights like a um like a
kickboxer he stands up right now he is
if you move him backwards normally he
can just lean against the ropes he's got
a long distance to go to the cage so he
doesn't fight very well going back
everything is studying at the end of his
shot yeah isn't it because
it's all about matchups like if the ufc
want to pump through the ringer you
think he beats jared cannon air no
you're out of your mind absolutely not
no no they pump they pump the word they
want
but dude he doesn't beat uh bronson but
they i think i think
quick his legs like it's like dead
weight everything's wasted everything's
dead weight with he doesn't push
anything no yeah she's just slapping him
out there he does
he does that well he's playing what i
hear
but he doesn't have any uh if he got
grappling dude he's too tall
doing something right there see overhand
or right dude strickland if he goes to
the body opens him strictly he gets hit
i've seen him in the jab out there
though he hasn't really landed guys he's
susceptible to overhand rights
he has to be tough he has a tattoo on
the back of his quad or his [ __ ]
hamstring maybe that [ __ ] hurt huh awful
i have no tattoos look at this if this
guy's attacking him
someone told me the foot and the hands
throat this guy's picking that up watch
he's going body jabbing the body
talking about he's dabbing the body and
then goes over he's going to go to the
top he sees the lean back
they notice look at he's going to the
body he's trying to get him forward oh
that jab's kind of landed for strickland
though
i think that that's the thing marvin
victoria said cause his jab's really
underrated that's [ __ ] effective
hasn't broke eye contact once it's crazy
he's just dead into him is stupid
effective
is funny strickland was trying to get
sponsors he said come on any [ __ ]
sponsors and he's like and they're like
what about this company's like no way
you're just turning them down they're
like what about this thing
see this guy geez right handling
you were scheduled to fight strickland
and then you're you're back right
that's right yeah right luke yeah
yeah yeah i know you're scheduled for me
that's been a good fight too
oh
like why would you stop that it's like
oh i love whenever they get clocked like
that well i'm chilling dude i'm chilling
it's like your boy who just puked at the
bar i'm good dude let me go
he's like yo izzy's next wow
[ __ ] wow i did not expect that no
he was a another dog too
damn yeah strickland had to learn the
hard way man
he's a world champion [ __ ] super
pissed oh man that's awesome that's an
ego thing dude yeah but you know you
what do you mean evil because he just
wasn't playing aggressively i can't
grapple at all so it's like just go in
there or force a grappling so he can't
just tee off here's the other thing even
if you don't if you're not you're saying
sean should have gone for the girl yeah
trying to wrestle it on the ground the
reason being is this is
it makes you hesitate for a split second
because you think i'm gonna take you
down which means your hands don't come
out as fluidly your kicks don't come out
so if i can freeze you for a split
second and potentially land the overhand
or the combination or get a takedown or
shoot so you think he was just playing
it like oh i got this yeah wear him out
real quick then hit him that was
beautiful boom but that's that's what he
said too in the in the press conference
he's like dude you guys don't think i
can stay with this guy we're like no
why would you want to try though but
he's also a world-class yeah
why would you why would you want to try
mma
miles teller missed it he's there on the
bottom right knockout and now he looks
he's like wait what happened oh miles
come on miles dude that knockout was bad
too dude does corner men are so mad
damn dude hendricks is he coming in hop
they they fast track this dude the title
shot too like strickland's the perfect
matchup for him he's gonna strike with
him
you can't give him cannon air you can't
give him you know some of these other
savages
if if you play the game standing beast
yeah if you play the game yeah
mop this dude has there ever been a dude
who got tired or like you know he lost
he's like don't touch me oh yeah really
oh yeah but like to the referee oh yeah
they probably just won't even come up
there they'd be like oh really yeah they
just dart out damn
look it's dramatic as hell
dude he looks like
he looks like gru's uh evil scientist
right
damn he's thinking [ __ ] what did i just
do what an idiot yeah you just can't
play that game no the guy's a tattoo of
a world championship belt on his [ __ ]
bicep from kickboxing
wow
i don't i don't understand i just don't
get it i don't get why you would even
think about standing especially in the
beginning of the fight
like why he's still fresh he's still
realizing his ass out yeah grind on it
just rush hang on the legs exactly hang
on the legs do something to slow him
down make him think about the takedown
second third round go ahead and open up
the stand up a little bit more but still
threaten the takedowns
i guess when we talk about fighter iq
this will go down in history as one of
the worst yeah that's a bad idea one of
the ones yeah which i'm disappointed in
strickland because you know title shot
how often do they come at least his uh
quarterman's in shape but um
he looks like what's his name conan he
looks like his little brother i thought
it was this is his little brother i
thought he was getting out he's just a
joke they keep finding these guys at att
what was that what was the pro wrestler
was the professor batman bigelow yeah
right there yeah bam bam but this guy's
got to be in the world's strongest man
with ucla two
what is joe wearing tonight what's going
on he's in a suit dude
he leveled up man he's john wick
[ __ ] john wick what is going on joe i
love it yeah he used to be scared to
wear a tie because he said people could
choke them out easy i'm like in what
world are you living in yeah where
people are choking people like the
casual person's gonna walk after you
just start choking with a tie but joe
rogan in a bow tie would be too funny
that would be sick god
i would love to wear a bow tie for like
my for for my analyst work problem is i
ca even [ __ ] when i look it up on
youtube i still can't tie that [ __ ] you
gotta get the clipboard
gotta go give me a bow tie clip on
nobody really looks good enough
no you gotta have a mustache
yeah i look ridiculous
wow gotta have one of those uh twisted
ones i think yeah right
yeah you gotta make an old fashioned on
impact yeah rogan a tie just doesn't i
mean he looks classy but just it's not
his thing is it
i'm not gonna lie he's cleaned his hands
up a bit huh he's taking that
not too hairy these days man not so
hairy shaving the hands they shaved
their hands that way they did dude
straight title shot
wow that was a great knockout
yeah it was filthy so i mean that and
that's why the ufc did it they knew
stylistic it was a nightmare for
strickland if he fought like this
this guy can intervene in the chain i
thought what she just proved which is so
silly unbelievable that's really good he
has to be kicking himself i could not
believe that yeah so there's two more
fights left looks like yeah i know you
have two big boys oh these these are
titles i don't even
book enough see matt this is gonna be
this is gonna be insane and then is he
candidates he's a pretty big favorite
but there's still great fights i have
i don't even know what to expect from
this one you give canada a shot
yeah i mean a shot of like mma busy
breaks his leg
no i mean he breaks his hand in a fight
or something
hits him clean yeah you got you you got
a third shot dude kennedy throws hard
yeah if you've been like all likelihood
is he wins a fight if he takes if he
takes and stands and stands his ground
like you did with uh kelvin gaslin oh no
it could end up being it he could in a
that's a bad idea for izzy he's got to
stick and move stick and move stay right
outside of the range how do you match up
with dizzy how do you beat izzy
i've got him going backwards eh i play
on the outside game and
yeah we're long enough is he is he's
taller than people think dude is he is
he is tall yeah
i've always been the tallest guy but
he's like oh [ __ ] because he feels like
he's just as taller taller than me
i mean
good fight
we go to the ground if any of these guys
is over
i mean i'm bucket hat one of my seasons
put it on dude my kids are in
next can't see him rock it doesn't pour
a get his hot sauce get his whiskey
justin gaichy
yuri doing the damn thing i love the
outfit oh my god i love the outfit that
was beautiful let's do
and when i want to get focused i use
kratom to fire up my phone i thought you
never asked dude let's take a look here
man get some steak why don't you grab me
a few pieces man cause i'm light-headed
i'll tell you what doesn't make me
light-headed kratem from happy hippo
it's my limitless bill when i'm doing
stand-up podcasting or just chilling
with the kids i'm on kratom
uh it's the best focused product i've
ever used best part it's all natural
y'all it's all natural the kratom is the
wild west but you gotta trust happy
hippo that's why i use it all right
kratom is like what cbd used to be and
that's why i trust happy hippo because
not all of them say what's in the bottle
how people does visit happy hippo
herbals.com use promo code thickboy for
20 off for life you can use that code as
many times as you want that's happy
hippo
herbals.com use sperm code stickboy for
20 off for life
hopefully uh trevor's getting me some
steak i'm pretty lightheaded yeah he's
uh making some more i think oh is he
yeah
savage on that grill yeah mike threw on
some more
he's pretty freaking good at it man
are you drinking anything no i wasn't
nothing huh i think i learned my life
we got tiger thick
i'll do i'll do a i'll do one tiger
thick
oh yeah
it's nice dude it's a nice little
whiskey i get this drippy wet coffee
here it's just sweating
you're sweating a little bit over there
chin huh not a little bit a lot bit
that's because chin's so hot and i'm
also standing too that's why daddy man
i'm physically hot right now how do you
and gary look
oh you see that he looks so good yeah
he's a savage i like his head man i was
just out there training with him and
moving a lot with him last week
he's very clean
very like you know he's a good mind for
the sport
ammunition is good i mean this is one of
my favorite tool ammunition what they do
so it's in uh like this one is it a uh
pinyo pinware
so they they uh do it in the wine bot
like barrels
yeah so it's different
the old wines yeah the old wine barrels
yeah yeah i love them that's what i've
noticed a lot of these bourbons are
doing
[ __ ] that looks good that looks so good
anything else sonoma
what's good a great bottling it looks
sexy yeah i like it yeah i love those
guys have me your uh how many yours
so many demons inside of that bottle
waiting to come out
yeah you now you're uh completely dry
now luke no no i call nothing cause i
think it's a good idea to get that belt
reward yourself a little tiger thick
after you win the belt yeah we'll take a
dig yeah
i mean i mean maybe with sponsored you
get the belt you grab a bottle of that
spiking on the cage
[Laughter]
uh crack your eyes brother like machine
gun kelly cheers brother
cheers
i don't know i'll call everybody i know
i don't want to break any rules
i think it's illegal to cheers with
water
with my cigars yeah
yeah i think you can i mean it's like my
degrees
cigars
it's fourth of july
take a chance it's a tough one
do you think it's gonna cost
you think the sprinklers my worst case
the sprinklers go off and all our
equipment's destroyed this is just worse
than the worst case that's the worst
case scenario that's horrible
oh yeah yeah who did who did that
picture right there of rogan
this guy r uh baines
it's like public enemy number one yeah
he sent the music what do you think
ma'am like
let me buy the original wow give me the
original dude that's the original one
that's awesome the media was coming
after i'm like i need that picture wow
yeah okay same guy did this one here no
that's my boy d was it deeb uh was it
gen d
uh he's nuts oh dos brac
yeah he's great the man he's the kid
from uh dublin yeah he's great nice
yeah he's great
from ireland huh kid from ireland
oh
uh san diego she came in she was like
i'll get done two days two weeks later
you know what i'm gonna need to stay a
little longer she did it all by hand
yeah oh yeah yeah all customers
go yeah the guy who did your guys said
is doing our set too brian yeah he's
great he's awesome i'm excited to see it
yeah it's like the wall art was like
based off the joe picture it's just
blending a little bit right yeah it does
so well it's like the whole thing it
works
that's a that's a dope
uh
led yeah that's nice
it pops nice the boys that raid yeah
rain made that
rain a lot of art i like it i like it
okay if he's there yes he's got more hey
so this is what so if max wins tonight
he drops the title goes to 55 and says
volk you can't get a rematch oh i bet
they pay him so much to do
like that let me get some of that
yeah i mean mike does not [ __ ] around
yeah it's so nice
as soon as we don't chew in the mic i
think we're good
right directly in it sorry
yeah
a little bit
that didn't sound too confident she's
like
how do you order yourself i was like i'm
good brother you do medium rare are you
like uh
you're a blue
rear plus or medium rare okay you know
most steakhouses like nice steakhouses
you can't order it well done
or you can't get steak sauce either yeah
yeah
like really nice ones in la especially
in new york if you're like can i get
well done to be like
oh yeah sulk me
oh damn she had salt in her back pocket
wow
oh you dropped all of it
[ __ ]
you didn't use all that did you i know
right good thing this isn't live
streaming like 10 000 people right now
he's like he's like this trying to go
and it's [ __ ] whole thing just knocks
down
you know
that was pretty funny
yeah this fight's tough man yeah if they
because if max were to win you're
definitely in the fourth one josh well
volkswagen to go back to the late kicks
sorry
he just said don't chew another mic and
i'm over here oh dude the people on
youtube love it actually asmr
um
vulcan go back to the late kicks like
you did in the first fight
you don't think max knows that
he didn't change anything when he fought
your rodriguez and your ear was tearing
up his legs i think volkswagen go back
to those
but just max has to do something special
he hasn't hit him with him yeah you have
to hit bulk with a knee i think it's the
only way look at this dome is doma built
to get punched in the [ __ ] speed 220
pounds dude he's like around this guy
he's right here
cartoon character what's that head
it just runs through like everything
like buses and everything you're talking
but i think if you looked at their like
last time they fought you look at who's
improved max always had some [ __ ]
performances man yeah when he fought
cater oh my god i said on that night no
one was beating him nobody was beating
up that thing max shows up we got
ourselves a flight but this dude's
different man oh yeah that's true it's
just like but like max has all the
opportunity to do something different
you know what i mean volks gonna do bulk
and he's he can win that fight every day
every night all night like that but max
has to go out of his [ __ ] if wins
this i think he goes up to 55. yeah for
sure he was telling me he was like dude
all i trained with because i was like 55
dude he's like oh i'm there with 55 in
seven years i train with no nobody under
my weight class or even at my weight
class he's like everybody's bigger than
me everybody yeah
this fight is crazy i just these dudes
are absolute warriors it goes the
distance
yeah yeah i don't know how i think so i
don't know how these guys
that's just his his
he looks like he's on some other worldly
bokonovsky
worldly level like the way he gets out
of the the choke from
what's the name that show with ortega
just like the type of fighting he just
that's why i fell in love with it it's
unbelievable he just never like there's
no quit
that guy will kill
like such a good guy too that's my
problem
you follow him on social media he's
always doing like his food stuff he's
always talking about
yeah you've never
great time to plug i'm going to be at
the blue note lounge uh july 29th in a
lot of tickets for max holloway free
tickets for max holloway it's always
opening up for you i heard uh yeah yeah
yeah july 29th trevorscomedy.com
manscape promo code
this
cfc
cfc
that's a great fight
oh yeah
actually like changed on with it with
thomas yeah well it looks like he's so
he cuts so much weight man does he get
down structures this massive he walks
around like 190 185 190 my size
it's like damn on this
man this is the one fight that it's
tough for me to pick i don't know oh he
got a stomach tattoo about a [ __ ]
somebody tough to pick it's tough to
speak against voglanovsky but i'm such a
big max hallway fan it's just my heart
uh wants max my head says volkanovsky
i love both of them you know i i really
do yeah i just want to see you guys
that's my guy though
you're gonna get you're gonna get a good
fight that's the biggest thing i love
max though when you guys when you when
you've shared
what 10 rounds with each other you guys
you understand these guys have yeah
they've already fought twice oh wow
that's their third fight so they know
that
is actually 2-0 against them but the
last one was such up for debate that
they they're getting a third one here
and max also won 200.
this is title or no yeah okay this is a
big one this goes to distance yeah yeah
a lot of money on this one it's like
[ __ ] these guys can't finish each other
there's just too much but i was telling
i was telling uh bookend officers on
food truck i'm like you know he's
talking about all these other fights i'm
like dude you have to
make it clear that you beat max hallway
otherwise we can't move on yeah because
max is such a face of the featherweight
division yeah until you clearly beat him
i can't move on how do you clearly beat
him did you
volk has to lay down the purpose perfect
punch in the world people forget how
good maxwell was at featherweight
like he's only lost his last loss
besides those volkanovsky ones was conor
mcgregor yeah
about whatever
all all time like
the best who max is max's tax said it
himself just last weekend that everyone
forgets about aldo aldo's the best hands
down go in terms of the 145. and the max
element he's already said like eight he
went almost 10 years undefeated you
can't take that away he he's got
different types he's got nothing oh no
no you can't say that you can't say that
he beat guys like cub swanson he beat
all the guys that were that are stunned
different time but because they're
better now that goes with every sport
you're saying jordan's not the best
because now always in yellow lebron
no there's an option
i think jordan's the best are you gonna
say joe montana is better than patrick
mahomes not a chance patrick
okay look you're i'm gonna use you i'm
gonna use your different different um
different times against you you're right
i think actually joe montana was the
better quarterback and i'm a chiefs fan
reason being is because guess what back
then the lineman could actually hit the
quarterback this year now like these
this day and age you can't even touch
the quarterbacks
but i i
but no quarterbacks are not hurt
and actually ran over by the way that's
fine but i'm saying as far as talent
wise i mean who's your montana no no no
no you can't say that yeah you can love
it because more talented than jose aldo
as far as complete mixed martial arts
yeah i would say complete yeah agree i
agree with you on that but here's the
thing though and i different times in
that situation but until volkanovsky
wins eight nine in a row title defenses
he's not the greatest i'm sorry then
khabib's not the greatest about time i i
didn't i never said that i never said
anyone that's your guy we've had this i
understand that i know beam's the best
no he is the best here he didn't to your
point
but here's the i agree with you he
didn't find long enough but here i will
i will say this though there is never
never in a million years there's never
has there ever been a fighter that was
more dominant than him in every single
foot to your point he didn't exactly but
he's but he's not the goat though i
don't think he could go to 55. no i
wouldn't say 55. i would say i can't say
55.
i would say overall i'm talking about
the sport it tastes like with i think i
think right now even though i
put put the steroid stuff aside and all
the dick pills stuff aside jon jones
hands hands down hands down the the he's
outside
but he's that's fine for both our
argument because he's done it a long
time and yeah he's done yeah exactly i
get it i get it but in terms of the the
most dominant fighter ever that's ever
stepped in the cage
he think about this he had never lost a
round
he never lost a round until that that
what fourth round against connor right
yeah where's like ah he lost connor yeah
whatever but it's like
other than that he had never really lost
a round i think he lost the the gate she
first round is what some of the judges
had it but if you look at that round he
was just walking him around like okay
he just i mean to your po i see i think
khabib's the best 55 of all time but if
i'm going off your
shoulder i can't
say that but here in 55 it's such a
short stint i think he's tied for the
most defensive so you could say he's the
best 55 pounder because i think there's
only three the one the longest title
defense has only been three
no one's ever defended it more than
three times i believe so khabib is right
there tight at the top so i figured in
55 i'd probably say it could be yes
you're right if i now that i think about
it now i have a second you caught me off
john jones just has so many moments that
stand out from his earlier career also
look at the guy's crazy moments
all those guys were older all those guys
were all they're kind of all their way
out khabib has done it yeah khabib done
gus was the tc gus was his hardest
fighter dc dc was 37 years old he's
still changing i get it i understand but
i said and even after that loss you want
to become heavyweight i get it again
like this he's always to me though dc
has always been better in heavyweight he
should have never been at 205 the only
reason he went to 205 because why
because it came easier because kane
he went to because he's like okay look
cain's
kane's in the heavyweight champ or he
was the heavyweight champ when he went
down that's why he that's why he went to
205 but but he didn't want to fight the
system but but go over john's fights
even he fought leo machine in his prime
he fought a steroid up vitor belfort
yeah
yeah
ryan bader i mean you go through him
like he's fighting right now
but john john looked like he was about
to get beat by three or four guys at the
end
would never ever ever show that but
they're also there
longer how much longer you've been the
champion that long you need to find guys
that motivate you that's where i can
that's where i defend john is i'm like
towards the end there he's like dude
i've been through all this stuff john
john heavyweight he's hard to get up for
these
some live meet yeah plus those guys
getting they're getting faster he's
getting older they're getting you know
they're getting bigger reyes is tall big
huge you know gus was tall all those
guys he had a hard time with because
they were so tall if you just put jon
jones and khabib next to each other you
just
really reflect on it khabib's has been a
lot more dominant
in turn and then with every one of his
but it's hard to say that i mean there's
fights where john has shown crazy
dynamic [ __ ] he's mad madness but
he's also used epo
public like there's a lot of [ __ ] that
you know john's cheating for and just
like you take a little which is he
didn't get buzzfeed
we all know you're doing epo johnny boy
you've been [ __ ] on that [ __ ] from
day one when tate he's take him in start
buckling people no oh no
i mean he obviously has those knocks
against him with usada and [ __ ] like
which attempt but it's also like i gotta
be honest those guys use fighting or
else on [ __ ] too but here's the thing
though i i'm not gonna know i don't hold
that against him i just don't think
anyone that's been i don't know positive
the tested positive shouldn't be allowed
to be in the go conversation i keep gsp
in that conversation what are you doing
at the top this isn't a goat
conversation yeah i mean it's like it's
always in the go it's always all a lot
of the goats are on steroids
yeah i don't think lebron james is mike
tyson
mike tyson was just used to the guilt
people's ears off
jumping two ways
all natural bro come on
there's no science diet there whatsoever
every almost every champion greatest
champion of all time in every sport is
steroided to the [ __ ] guilt
vanderholt should have been pumped in
the olympia
crazy it's just what they did back then
you can't not go for it no there was
like a steroid guru i heard that just
like would just do everybody i mean
like later in his career i heard [ __ ]
fell in his name's bro but even this
even this conversation started off with
the best the best featherweight in the
world you could say arguably would be
would be to me or is jose aldo and even
max came out he said you guys all for
real because they asked him a question
that's such a good guy he's such a great
guy super nice jose giving him respect
jose's wc career was magnum
he never knew what he was going to do he
was so good
and then uh but he also but then also
you know we talked about like look at
that guy versus this guy like ever that
jose alder versus
this
max
no i mean uh
think about that well here's the thing
flying knees i think i said i think jose
knocks him out no no no no
i think i should have you sat around
that works him out i think that holds up
beats max that jose alda beats max this
max now don't know only because only
because look at you look at no jose aldo
max maxwell he hit back so hard in the
beginning that fight you got to remember
him back then jose was kicking a lot
more he didn't he stopped kicking
because he's dealing with injuries yeah
so when he gets back to his kicking
which he has been the last couple fights
and he's looked fantastic there's a
thing though too like a little bit he's
just let's think about this remember he
just pieced up remember that connor
starched hey you're yeah yeah you're
right you're right you're right jose
aldo
but he'd already been champion for how
long they still understand for 10 years
i think these are the two goats right
now i agree these two
goats and whoever's the go to the yeah
you got you gotta go short-term memories
who's the goater
how can max be the goat then nobody
hasn't owned them
he didn't own him at all also didn't get
started tripping on the first flight
owed him the first fight he [ __ ]
broke seconds that's true max took
jose's best two fights in a row but also
but connor beat max also that's what i'm
saying yeah yeah and that was a
different that was a different max back
then max was like 14 years old back then
max is the max max's max turned a corner
i'm actually in the corner
there's a lot of guys that turn the
corner you can see that championship
mentality and they're blind their eyes
and their brain everything switches over
like
you're on charles
mission yeah i agree yeah i just want to
double check we turn the heat on again
do you think there's more fights in
vegas knights of ufc you like you know
when you watch basketball you want to go
play basketball do you think there's
more street fights on the strip after
this no yeah they're just like
influencers unless you have connor
fights yeah
all the double shots oh the dublin crowd
we're looking at
some americans
that that night when i won the title
they were rioting everywhere they shut
down all vegas that's awesome yeah
that's crazy
94 94 connor jose knocked out jose aldo
i won that before
the whole place no uh wideman no wyman
i'd be wideman come and he knocked out
jose i remember i was like i l i just
got the title i was like i was like i
want to go watch the fight i had him
carry me i had prescott carrying me back
out to the [ __ ] cage i sat down i
looked up connor knocked him out and
like oh no and then i had to get carried
back out one crashes
it was [ __ ] up
did weidman retire was he still i think
he's still trying to come back i saw him
and i saw him in the cage
behind the cage leg break
i think he's trying to say he's back
fully training though he's sparring
broken off he's just a little power plug
isn't he yeah
is max is kind of showing dominance
though in this round i think he's he's
definitely got the
oh oh my god
folks oh folks throwing
folks looks like he's he's trying to
land that shot
he confident put max out if he lands
like this he's throwing hard
do you think joe barron is uh teammates
that have to wear sunglasses or
it's weird oh that dark shade
as long as it's not too dark you know
you gotta bring it to life yeah it's
true
could be blue light glasses good for his
eyes you know lockers
i'm sure he probably went bankrupt i
think that canceled the pillow guy you
gotta take out the blue light
yeah fellow guys struggle city right now
apparently
damn pelton
no the my pillow guy
oh these guys every time don't
they just know what's gonna happen
everything five rounds of this this type
of you know it's gonna be but it's like
it's phenomenal
but there's just not that like
it's just so goddamn competitive yeah
but it would be weird if this one goes
decision two you could see a finish here
even though i think it was a decision
you could oh
[ __ ] nice
he's committing to every shot like he
hasn't
he's going to put max a well oh look at
him i think he's believing in his stand
up right now is the first two fights i
think he thought oh well max can't be
touched on the feet now he's believing
it well he's got he's finishing his
shots better oh [ __ ] focus man i'm
telling and i'm max hawley fan it's
i think you need to drop pretty soon
here talk's about to phone this thing
this is also the biggest tv i've ever
seen in my life what is this that is uh
9 000 square feet dude
my studio apartment right here target
that's target no hell no i don't know
where that came from
i don't know where we got it best buy
chin you know i don't know i don't know
i was like what's the biggest
oh
magic up here it's a really tiny screen
i just i was a nice elbow on the inside
by max yeah i watch on my phone
illegally
like i thought you're doing well man
yeah these boys are swimming which is
definitely different than the first two
fights someone's getting i don't know if
this goes distance fellas the way that
well the first fight they were both
throwing down
but the legos were the more dominant in
the second fight they didn't throw as
much it was very tentative on both sides
that was sick
did you see him in the uh
before the wayne's talking [ __ ] my god
they were going at it man i think it was
a mutual respect though yeah but it
wasn't like you suck it was like you
better bring it and and maxwell was like
i got the fire brother you know he was
just they were going at it man must be a
trip to be max right now because you
went through two [ __ ] wars with him
you thought you won both fights and
you've dominated every single person
that has stepped in front of you since
you feel like you're the champion but
you're just not getting that dude in the
middle any respect for it oh would you
say oh yeah what does that do it's uh
ice cold so it's uh getting out the
swelling so they push on the swelling
and they push it away from your eye so
it doesn't like build up
right there
it's always where they put the thing in
the nose i love when the coach is like
telling like what to do like they're not
like listening to them they are they're
like the adrenaline but is it sometimes
the adrenaline just going so much like
man you got to watch for those times
because they gotta keep it simple yeah
but there's the coach and then there's
like the hype man he's like yeah man get
your [ __ ] bread up here what does
that have to do with things you watch
too much boxing no i don't like that
forever oh really that's all that's like
yeah that's all boxy [ __ ] there's no
hymen for mma no that's all boxing
boxing they got like 10 corners but yeah
everybody's just saying a relative [ __ ]
they're bored
get in there yeah you got to throw more
things without your brother is great
because you're here [ __ ] them up man
yeah yeah i'm trying that's the goal
yeah i'm trying my hardest man he's
pretty [ __ ] good well now like the
commissions have rules that you
basically can't it's called over
coaching which is where you can't just
say get up get up no [ __ ] i gotta get up
from my body you can't do that you gotta
tell me what you mean be professional
yeah yeah give me a way to get up you
can't just yell hit him hit him kick him
in the [ __ ] you can't yell that but it
is weird that you can have anyone
just throw that one out you can have
anybody in your corner
that's what's crazy i could have my dad
who's never but see that's the thing
though and i've said this for the
longest time who was it that i i told to
do and uh oh mike perry and then he
tried to do it is uh i said oh contest
yes do a fan contest or sell it to a
sponsor hey
rayne wants to be in my corner yeah pay
me 15 grand
from
rain let it rain rain down those punches
right the new gummy bear flavor yeah
20 grand i'm down two rounds dude
more rain
yeah that that makes sense now your boy
mike perry is fighting uh like a page
i didn't think it was i don't know why
but it's oh that's a big shot by volk
volks beat him to the punch right now
yeah it's a power but [ __ ] max can
take it well he's running his
combinations fly in a tight phone boom
he knew max could take a shot when he
fought dustin poury
that was insane max can take a shot no
doubt i mean
legend of max was dropped who's dropped
max
connor connor connor dustin he was like
but he's honored
his eyes have always really been there
actually dustin heard him good dustin
nothing got hurt
in the in the 55 pound fight
yeah yeah oh get up on my max there max
is just a little groundbreaking
in that phone that's what volkl was
saying because 55 he's like dude i'm
strong on these 55ers
i don't think he realizes
does islam did they announce his next
fight
i mean there's talk that's gonna be the
title
he's working for that right now i know
he is it should be the title i know
khabib's buying for it for him which
goes a long list he is but the problem
is though right is that now there's no
champ
oliveira's like why would i fight why
would i fight you why don't i just fight
conor
yeah well because he's gonna be like
well connor's fighting crazy quit
waiting
like that ufc just oh big shot
huge shot by vogue and he's oh look
upset that's bad and he's kind of folks
talking [ __ ] hey
champion he's trying to market himself
now champion vibe
well i don't know
that might be shocking right now when
the cuts go this way is when they stop
it when the cuts go this way is when
they don't stop it so when i talk about
north south north south is the worst
yeah because it goes like it goes
against against the nerves or whatever
that run in your face you get it really
bad you can end up with also eye drop
what do they do if it's like in between
um
this thing's getting to him
he's going to start getting desperate
man after this performance you're crazy
you don't think volk is the goat
he's defending the title what four times
five times what was they did for ten
years five eight times nine times in the
seventies dudes you're acting like
people in the past and actually like
charlie chaplin they still had
confidence
they still had to beat people no i feel
you they still have to be a top level
guys he had to stay motivated for 10
years to be undefeated that long is jim
brown the best running back
i don't know is he no you tell me no he
he only ran against white guys there's
no blackout wow wow we're going to babe
ruth the best baseball player there's no
cubans throwing heat out of them you
feel me these white guys dude
different time man
you got to give those guys in the past
they're they're due buddy
there's nothing else jose aldo has been
on top of the game for a long time
he's still young he's like 34 or
something like that thirty four thirty
five that's five years
yeah he's like 70. he's 77. yeah he
looks like he's like seven robbie lawler
should be like 97 then yeah
but these boys are stolen no don't get
me wrong they're i mean you could say
josie aldo or volkanovsky
i'm not going to fight that or max
yeah matt really is still it's still all
three of those guys are in the in the
running right now yeah it's been this
fight also go talks a little weird it is
to be honest we don't even need we
shouldn't even talk about it it's kind
of over yeah it's kind of after this
fight dictates
between all three of them who's the goat
nothing's worse than someone's like how
would bruce lee do against volcanoskin
like get out of my face
bruce lee never thought we know that
right
did you know that trevor i did not know
that yeah you know dude tell your friend
who's on shrooms all right i got you
bruce lee got a b call back he got beat
up a couple times
i've heard by uh uh what uh jeans
you know judo jean labelle that's what
the the brad pitt and uh once the time
in hollywood that's that actually
happened yeah i know i've heard he told
me some stories
oh okay yeah gene is pretty legendary he
was not shy about his stories he's a
monster you know he's playing
did you see one time in hollywood
stephen yes yeah yeah so you know when
uh brad pitt is fighting the fake bruce
lee in the movie yeah and they're
fighting and he takes them toss them
into the car that actually happened in
hollywood like that like quentin
tarantino didn't make that up oh bruce
lee's family like this ridiculous that
never happened and then jean lebel's
like no it actually did happen that's
why it's in the movie yeah his family
was so pissed
yeah all these guys back in there i
heard he put together putting the q-tip
in the eyes
a lot of sleep on set i've heard that
too yeah
yep they all think oh that's not good
that's a oh that's a lifeline that is
not good it's a new tattoo yeah
he's so gay he's got so much bone
structure one more shot right there
that's just a gusher that's gonna be bad
yeah i mean that's what just looks like
a walking i'm surprised that doctor let
it go
yeah right doctor's like you'll figure
it out here's advil
what's she doing
what are we
it's in the third but i got my i got
bulk up two rounds do you get that that
last one was pretty good for max
though the end of it yeah yeah yeah so
you think you got two zero josh i got
two two zero volts definitely volt last
last
you know what i'm saying like folks
damage which the judges pride themselves
on damage he's definitely throwing more
heat
max is so game though dude you just keep
coming max doesn't look like he belongs
at 145 pounds max is so much bigger but
then 55 he's too small it's weird he
looks so big i know did he see him
against like pouring at 55. he looks
normal it looks like he's like
built for that yeah
we just need more weight classes too
absolutely 100 i think we only need one
we need the 165 bumping one seven to one
seven
five because there's already not enough
good heavyweights why we have like
there's from one from 185 and up there's
not enough good
fighters in the nfl they're all in the
nba that's ridiculous
there's just not enough of them 225
there's not a there's not enough of them
josh is a sizes you need to do you just
want three guys i should go 10. no no
i'm a realist
should go 55
65 70. the heavyweight division's
already five 205 225 and now yep you
guys
it will never happen
there's not there's not enough boxes
every five pounds these guys and that's
why that's why boxing stuff watson's
like you you're like he's so much bigger
than me it's five pounds bigger than you
bro yeah step up and fight yeah oh like
there's all these champions that won't
fight each other and they're fine max is
getting beat to the punch right now man
but to josh's point like there's not
enough talent at the heavier weight
class at 185 and on up there's not
enough talent you're already struggling
even at 185 it's kind of a weak division
there's good fighters there but there's
like the top five six beyond that is
like just watered down that was like
back in your day those things no no
there's more guys this guy but they are
soft you know you're closer to 40 than
you are than you are 30 buddy
josh is like a sneaky he's like he looks
like he's 30 when he's really like 50.
yeah josh could be 50.
he's like he really is johnny
like yes trevor is the youngest boxer
[Laughter]
not a [ __ ] wrinkle on your face bro
do you like just you wear a foundation
is that like to cover them up because it
looks good yeah
all that heat in here the wrinkles just
smell dude
we're watching a fight guys
tonight i feel like i'm in the fight i'm
sweating so much right now what's going
on
you look really good what are you doing
with your hair today is that jocko
that's jocko and cam haynes
and then you got uh
what's that actor's name ratner my boy
ratner oh i love ratner
he's [ __ ] the best he's been around
every time
he comes over
this guy is that paris
i see what you're saying looks like her
though right how did you get those seats
dude she did some work to her face she
don't look the same anymore pierce
hilton yeah that's not her but i hear
you no but she did some work though i
hear you
yeah
there's that sneaky little hook hook jab
landing privilege whatever happened to
her she got married right she got
married yeah yeah and then she makes all
the money djing what happened to her
other friend uh the one she was getting
in trouble with richard yeah
she made uh uh uh
good charlotte she made like benji
madden from good child i forgot about
like three kids oh wow yeah and her
dad's lionel richie so she's like i'm
all set on money yeah she's good she's
good
also if i'm paris hilton why am i djing
no i'm bored you know yeah it's like why
is shaq he's just bored
fair point
she's making probably what a million a
gig
not that because it makes it feel like
she's doing something but she's really
not me like what so all the dj's in
general you just put on your ipod uh
playlist yeah you kind of make what
makes all the money what does he make
like 18 million years he's got a
residency investment
shaq's making money now about
personality because you're in vegas
you're like oh i'm gonna go see the guy
i know and then just correct
volk winning this round too it's close
but he's winning this round but he's
just landing the cleaner shots inside
the phone booth look at his eyes but now
volkswagen actually puts the pressure on
him
vlog's questioning himself a little bit
you can no yeah
volkswagen i mean max is bringing your
dude max is bringing it how often do the
refs get clock trying to break
really now he's too far away oh
look at that motion is so brutal
sometimes yeah i love when the ref in uh
nfl just gets something out
for whatever reason it feels good
damn
slow-mo does not look good for max just
the speed hey but you know what volcano
volk called this out though he's like
hey when he fought cater when when max
fought cater i was like oh man it's the
best he's ever looked he looks so great
on point and then volk replies like yeah
he never looked that good against me
and it's it has to do with who you fight
it's just a different fight yeah
different style fight and cater you know
phenomenal striker boxer meat potatoes
tough as [ __ ]
that's max always but max right now look
max's his whole claim is that he's the
best boxer in the in he's getting out
box right now
it's hard to say that and i'm gonna so
bad
how many guys trying to stick their dick
in that oh my god this guy you gotta
slow down the only thing
is free knowledge oh it's all about
freaky it's about free you know that's
so great training camp go check out my
own fans
yeah
damn that's nasty
this is round four [ __ ] yeah man that
cut is bad i mean one one one solid
puncher that might stop this right now
it's three three to nine is it you have
a three dot yeah sprite right i agree i
agree yeah three zero yeah i'm actually
watching the fight
trying my guys it's three and and what's
interesting is bulk's up you know three
zero and he's still taking chances
i don't think it's in him to lay back
no neither neither guy yeah i don't
think it is i don't think he's in either
one of them like you said
look at that look at that back over here
just crazy the amount of work he's just
willing to do it
i don't ma max isn't going to keep up
with this
oh [ __ ]
might put him away
he might put him away because i love the
ufc twitch you can always see the guys
who are super thirsty to get on
like oh my god this is the best fight
i've ever seen i'm like it's good it's
good you know it's nice i know what
you're doing yeah yeah
dude yeah you should tweet something out
and be like oh my god this is insane
dana eighty dollars just for this oh my
god how can i repay you tell you what
two free tickets on my show in irvine
july irvine july 22nd
who's the fembot cage side
you see that thing there's some there's
like a full thin bottle know like
what the hell is that thing
this is just
it's just a war man we're all silent
just folks i know it's just max you know
he's just gonna keep coming and just to
no avail he's not gonna win
so i guess if you're max where do you go
let's say max were to lose this five
nothing where do you go josh
uh he's gonna i mean i think i think
vote's gonna go up he'll probably vacate
the title i think he'll go up first see
if he gets a win and then give max if he
gets a win maxwell will probably fight
because the winner of yaya ortega would
get the next shot
but i don't think so i don't think
ortega is getting another shot yeah i
think if yayer wins he gets a shot you
can't do ortega match ortega volcano
yeah here's a problem for him for for a
volk oh i don't know he's a problem with
his leg kicks the different styles of
kicks he's not going to be as freelanced
to just throw punches like this now the
takedowns he's going to have to work
aggressively for him because your's
gotten way better at take down defense i
would be worried about yahya in those
championship rounds against them no i
agree with you i agree with you
let's not let's let's remember that yeah
yeah you're still being honest yeah he's
gonna get broken like frank yeager would
break him but he has the ability to
throw something for talent
it's going to be something different
because that's the style that he fights
is different folk's not going to be able
to just stand in front of him and tell
him
look at th you have to have a crazy
intangible to beat volk max can't beat
him he doesn't have enough power it
doesn't have this [ __ ] freakish [ __ ]
spinning [ __ ] you have to do spinning
[ __ ] oh oh
you went for like a weird spinning thing
yeah voke is just strong
who else at that weight class is good
uh uh at here
yeah i mean 45 coming up
not really like anybody
there there's there's some sleepers that
we're not thinking about
yeah bring up the rankings because
there's a guy why is his name supposed
to get the title fight right he just
beat colvin cater
oh emmett josh emmitt
sounds like
i tell you who's the sleeper well you
got josh edmond who you know josh he's
not he's gonna get owned by either one
of
you
though he's got some power
very technical but also i look at hey i
also love you guys like bryce mitchell i
look at guys like brian mitchell he's
that guy that like oh he doesn't seem
like he brings a lot to the table but he
finds ways to finish fights and wins
bryce's dogs
he's a dog but he's not gonna he's not
an elite oh jeez man well no one's beat
him yet
those guys i don't know arnold allen to
me is a problem if he keeps winning he's
getting a big fight next
arnold he's he's always had to go he has
a problem it's a problem he's a problem
yeah he's sticking with the problem he
seems like he's getting stronger
mitchell too dude bryce is a problem
that other kid number two number ten too
i don't know how you say his last name
evolov or whatever he's good as well
then he's still undefeated i think he's
like 15-0 or 16-0 i mean yeah damn can
you click on him yeah chin
yeah oh yeah the kid what's he's really
good at oh 16 and three yeah he's a
problem wait no 16 what's is he
undefeated russian right
no that's not that's that's how many
fish finishes so what's his route 15-0
15 last two no he has that's not a
we got here loss he's
three we got arnold allen we got arnold
allen doing the damn thing
they also got you know our boy bryce
mitchell
yeah
hopefully they don't pair up bryce
mitchell
who who did eveloff just be sure
mitchell
oh
nice combination right there god max's
[ __ ] game how do you not love max
oh those those light kicks are adding up
only be uh
and he
just took him down split decision nick
lentz yeah oh my gundy
yeah
to me if i betting horse dude arnold but
if you look at guys i split the decision
with nick lentz i mean that means that
he's probably not a great matchup for
guys like bryce mitchell guys that are
good wrestlers
he's got good wrestling but he's good on
the feet as well allen poses the biggest
threat yeah i don't know how the guy is
about to put money up for dogs all the
guys that go out against the champion
england
he's in england well what jim jim um i
don't even know out there no
it's england so i just figured all the
english guys just get together i wonder
if he's if he's with um
with those guys at shoot fight and you
know you know arnold allen's dad was a
strong fighter
who's he with arnold allen's dad was a
strong super strong man
i don't even know what that is that's
the vegetables also he's tri-star star
he goes okay got it smart yeah that
explains a lot why are you so good yeah
frost does a good job with those guys
literally because his dad was a strong
man and uh he would see his dad do
steroids and it was like you never do
this yeah he was like he like scared him
away from it he's like never ever get
started on this [ __ ] wow you think it's
horrible
i mean
when you see it you know like my dad
used to smoke and i was like god this is
disgusting never smoked gotta wish my
dad
yeah max pride down four nothing
it could be three one after the last
round but you gotta figure this corner
is like okay yeah you need to finish
this fight i hate to tell you you need
to finish oh nice uppercut and look at
volk just still doing the damn thing
phenomenal shape
oh my god both like oh
great
no he's not what are you doing it's like
they're both meeting potatoes
like he can't what can max do to win
this fight right now you can't do
anything
like you gotta
throw like wrestling what are you gonna
do wrestling you're not gonna choke him
out
yeah it'd be tough right if ortega
couldn't get it done what was the the
attempt to go wrestle was just like
doesn't seem to waste and now volcano is
usually buying time here just throwing
bombs yes
going for broke trying to line up a head
kick how does not everyone just don't
want to throw knees i feel like vogue is
like the only thing you get
that calf kicks really changed the game
in terms of
how fighters fight
god how many people have sunglasses on
in this [ __ ] day
it's all about blood splatter you know
splash zone point their cage the big
white ones are just like
ridiculous yeah they do wearing dark
shades at night like in in that arena
you can't see anything i mean as larry
david said wearing sunglasses inside
unless you're blind you're just an
[ __ ] you know
now yours don't count luke cause yours
are like cool looking kind of an [ __ ]
too no but but they're not dark cause i
can see your eyes yeah and then i'm like
oh maybe he needs them for his vision
you know
like they're like those night vision
ones we're also a model so i shut my
[ __ ] mouth
bringing out the color of life the
mushrooms just get a little brighter
what kind of brand are those where do
you find something like that what are
they what are they again
yeah you know by radar
by radal
yeah by radar or radal check their
special forces rado
they're probably like a thousand bucks i
don't know
that's your coach and that's your girl
this is my road dog oh dope is that she
has got me everything
she takes every step for me so i don't
take a step back
that must be nice it's pretty cool
helps me business in life and you just
focus on doing the work everything yeah
that's nice
it's pretty badass man it's helping me
you probably wish you had our lives you
know i bet you wish you had her a lot
earlier in your christmas
it's amazing yeah working with
perfecting athletes so she's like
understand the nutrition she cooks bomb
and she's just there to like support
gives me water and
meals everything just to propel me
sounds exhausting so i can be the best
i feel sorry for you i don't know why
she does it trevor you have to cut
weight for any reason
me do you want to cut weight i don't see
you down in one i don't know where he's
gonna get it we're
i'm trying to add weight the fatter you
are the funnier you are so i'm trying to
you know
really get up here
no i would never need to cut weight
you've always just dressed a little toe
kick
i assume your parents are yeah yeah my
dad's a slender man is he yeah he's just
like he never really packed on weight
he's like a flat ass oh yeah the
flattest i got no ass ah that's a shame
yeah i don't know
maybe some deadlifts kept myself my
buddy mark how do you drive the nail man
with no ass
how do i oh how do i lay it down yeah
how are you driving with us mentally
yeah in my dreams telepathy to her
saying yeah girl you know you're taking
i got a [ __ ] d4 in this hammy you
know you're [ __ ] you're taking this d
girl in college i took creatine a little
bit of test boosters for you know senior
year hell yeah i was i was probably the
best i ever looked very bloated though
very bloated
but that v-neck in an oversized watch
dude man i was swimming and pushing
coming quick did you go to college
trevor i did where yeah san jose state
oh really yeah san jose oh really we're
we're kind of from that he's from santa
cruz i'm from san jose oh yeah san jose
state man nice wow
kids it's either that or northridge and
northridge is too close to my parents
house smart man i just wanted to get out
smart man yeah
enjoy it yeah man i it was a blast what
do you think of san jose i actually
liked it i thought it was a good middle
ground from going from a small town to
san jose to l.a yeah there's like a
million people up there so it was like a
big city basically you're saying you
like asian girls love them
no more steak trevor man put some weight
on look at that
i'll take some ritz crackers please yeah
i'll do another one for the main event
hey did um san jose is a big party
school yeah san jose had his problem
yeah he had some massive he's like
that's what he's like
lucas you won't find a bigger [ __ ]
hater of san jose than luke rockwell
i didn't think i would have fun there i
actually had a great time
i mean where i went was named playboy uh
number one party school for a number of
years where'd you go you want to see
colorado
see you boulder yeah oh oh yeah
i know that's a party yeah
it's a little air here you've done the
santa's improv
oh yeah it's a great club it used to be
like a theater but yeah it's basically
they used to see 450. i think they said
like houdini used to do [ __ ] there yeah
it's a great club dude one time i was
doing uh san jose improv and they asked
me they're i never do sundays right
cause i get back home to the kids like
you gotta do sunday it's a big deal i'm
like all right and this i but you know
you booked it hey guys you guys got it
as a shutout over there
yeah first yeah
i think max might have won the fourth
round maybe they booked months and
months out well the 49ers were in the
super bowl [ __ ] and i was at san jose
improv
there was
40 shut up
they're like we're so sorry man so
friday saturday sold out sunday 40
people how was it sunday show though it
was 40 people dude
i was like hey everyone just come to my
green room
sometimes when it's just like a small
show sometimes it's lit yeah you used to
dress into it you try to address the you
know the elephant yeah yeah the 49ers
here you all don't give a [ __ ] about
sports cool that's what i said i was
like you guys i if i were you i would
leave right now and watch this for your
49ers super yeah or would you guys like
when you go up on stage you just like
update with the score real quick yeah
you know because mentally they're there
well that's tough you have the super
ball playing on the phone that's tough
yeah dude it was a tough one
yeah volkanovsky dude shut out daddy
yeah dominated he's going to be i
guarantee gets on the viking calls for a
55. dana already called he said hey if
he wins this fight he's like he can just
say whatever the [ __ ] he wants to go if
he wants to go 55 he can go 55. he's
going for this yeah i think he has two
that's the big money fights
but but who's gonna fight he's gonna eat
up by islam
charles oliveira gonna eat him up what
about chandler that'd be a fun fight you
weren't thinking that way no i wasn't i
was on one right yeah yeah two stocks
yeah taylor's the money fight right now
he is he's the nate diaz money fight
yeah the connor money fight he is the
fiercest yeah look at them dude they
gotta just respect all the way so they
just get on a flight looking like that
like yeah yeah
man i mean stitched up
yeah but imagine being in the middle
seat and you look over and see that's
where it's tomorrow oh and you'd be
surprised ufc don't fight first class so
you're like [ __ ] row b on south west
yeah like did you just fight for the
title yeah you're not having peanuts
you're not talking about the contusions
in your legs too and like just oh yeah
you're like limping through the airport
oh draw [ __ ] just like the edema
setting in your legs the swelling yeah
man when i thought you guys hear what
the score was gelatin legs
who cares dude is he dominated i think
it was at least at least three hours
at least 4-1 what is even the he
dominated the whole agreement yeah it's
not even a conversation of like
questioning rogan just went dude that's
when you know it's bad
you know i thought uh gabriel gonzaga
kicked my leg so many times i had to be
in a wheelchair through the airport i
couldn't walk the next day i won the
fight i couldn't walk they did carry me
through a [ __ ]
awful yeah it's my first fight with like
those leg kicks everything that
adrenaline comes down the next day
your leg goes oh say less we're gonna
swell up my first fight with gil i was
kicking so much i kicked his elbow
probably like 30 times in that fight
[ __ ] man i was at the party that night
just trying to hobble my way around i
just kept drinking more and more like
give me more tequila yeah then you just
give me more
so the information is like just pumping
your legs you're like
you get out you get off the fight week
and you come back like from the face
what do you do that for the week
painkillers trevor i'm glad you asked
but you you're not training you're not
doing anything you're just relaxing no
for that week no yeah no you're not
doing unless you have like a flawless
victory they want to go in the gym like
yeah i'm back guys
knockout or something yeah you're
probably in the gym that next week yeah
some of those just those first round
like 30 second knockouts you're like i
didn't really that's why they got on the
mic like hey i want another fight like i
want to fight now you're good to go
those dudes are broke you said what yes
anybody who's back in the gym
is a scrubber broke
if you're back in the gym
i mean um
on a monday
after a fight yeah you've like you
you've got no sense yeah man you gotta
take a break not very professional yeah
most coaches won't let you back in the
gym i mean it's just casey can you hear
who he's calling out or no one has a
[ __ ] air piece
god damn it jen i thought you always had
an earpiece look what's that thing
around your neck who cares joey look
you got bts [ __ ] quality for my phone
to communicate with the guys
no i'm not what do you sell wouldn't
that be lit you just you just sell it
you don't have to sell anything big old
dick that's all you're selling yeah
gave me 50 grand straight up just to
just to do free content for like oil up
and [ __ ] or what no just like just in
just cooking and like like
cooking like what hey guys
no no it's just normal [ __ ] training you
don't have time
to just change the training because just
just training everything training and
build up
at least
oh vince mcmahon's like is that not
doing well is that no that was triple h
no but that vince mcmahon was next to
him
oh dude that's annual and my wife is
latina so we celebrate him he's massive
massive huge carol g oh yeah do you got
like 50 mil on the ground you know
what's up dog yeah i tapped on oh hold
up big time they made him i love her as
much
oh right here they made him dark dark
dark
yeah too much right that was dark yeah
that's just like that's like way too
much man
yeah too much that was that was what was
the verdict should i go outside
oh hey did we uh do we don't want to set
off the [ __ ] job do we turn the
heater on the best thing yeah we have
like a little back patio either oh man
did we turn the heater up yet yeah
i [ __ ] know him this guy's a beast
yeah
this is the main event what's his name
does he have a nickname
yeah yeah he's insane right hey trevor
welcome to the show bro i don't know if
you wanna miss this
are you on twitch no i'm not me neither
does it go the distance does he get him
out of there or do you think i think he
uh gets a a
knock off home run
third round walk off he's just like
i'm gonna go light one of these up what
do you want me to tell me to do
yeah you do hey guys look it's manscape
time [ __ ] you asked for it they
listened i can't do it
that's a long breakdown use probable
code cfc
oh let me do this while trevor's taking
a little cigar break make sure you make
it back for the main event if you want
dude ah but i'll tell you what your bush
needs a break and that's where my
friends at manscape come into play here
all right they brought back the ultra
smooth package it's time to stop drop
and order this premium shaving kit
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower
4.0 is the best electric shave for your
balls but if you're looking for a closer
save to go bear down there then the
ultra smooth package is the perfect set
it's time to shave that bush of yours
fellas let's get right to the roots with
the discount just for you bros get 20
off free shipping at manscape.com with
the promo code cfc
dude this this kit is insane the ultra
smooth package i'm talking the crop
shaver razor crop effoliator the crop
gel men you no longer have to borrow
your lady's razor for the precise trim
dude get it for your dad get it for your
hairy aunt you know get it for anybody
has hair
problems callum doesn't need this he
needs all the hair you can get uh you
get the crop of foliater crop gel and
when it's time to shave the crop shaver
was designed for shaving the groin with
confidence it's not gonna nick your nuts
that's why i love it flashlight do it at
night it's fantastic get 20 off free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with
code cfc manscape.com smooth out your
fellas with the relaunch ultra smooth
package from the fellas at manscaped
your nuts will thank you
back to the program
middleweight rankings so sean strickland
probably drops to like six
no probably lower than that
yeah yeah
yeah because i guess uh peter was the
middleweight rankings
yes ranked or was it right but you got
victoria versus whittaker coming up too
in september in paris that should be a
good fight so he was four yeah he's
going to drop but he just lost two
pair which is all we're doing at 12.
sorry he's like oh they got straight
ranked right that's like where does
strickland deserve the four spot after
beating jack manson like how in the
world did they bump him the rankings are
strange dude that's so stupid they
didn't all sort of dare tell at eight
they just like and then
derek brunson in front of polycaster
right now what what's going on and how
does strong jump into them it's just
what they want how they dictate what
they what i think they're meeting i
think they have social media though that
does their their rankings and then they
make their adjustments they have media
that scratches their back
ringings are like the hall of fame it's
like whatever they like when they choose
it's like come on i mean
speaking of that but if you need paulo
then you're sick yo speaking of that
speaking of the whole speaking of their
hall of fame
correct might be number two how how how
does how do you have the hall of fame
and you don't and i understand why they
don't have frank shamrock because he
turned it down they have offered a tumor
called times he turned it down oh how do
you know i have jen's pulver wait oh you
know what he's done how do you not have
jen's pulver actually you know what i
beat paul the right way i like being
number one i mean [ __ ] i mean look at
marvin marvin vitoria barely [ __ ]
he didn't really put it on paulo well
and paula was like if i go out there and
finish this dude like if you finish him
but if victoria beats whitaker then
victoria still be ranked pretty high
right
yeah
whitaker and then i go smoke polo costa
which he couldn't even touch
i debate i i'm over him all day long all
day long
yeah you know those
rankings man it's the wild west it
really comes out it's how you win and
also how you play ball you know how you
play ball yeah and i don't know
obviously who you are it's all works
i think this this this can probably go
down as a finish here by brown three or
four that's what i said yeah i think as
he gets them matter of form yeah if you
go if it hands early i'm going to go
with cannon here though can't ever catch
oh interesting see i think kendra's
gonna have to take some chances and do
it early on and get caught really yeah
he's too slow that might be you might be
right you might be right there
is he's a bad man he's a bad man he's
feeling himself man but when and when
guy's rushing he lights them up anytime
anybody rushes in he's about so much
dynamic and balance but he has hits from
like awkward spots
what a girl was hitting him yeah hit him
on the inside yeah he took the shot and
he was so balanced out and he came back
from like butt balance he hits some
angles people aren't expecting dude if
he wins this
uh [ __ ] pierre is interesting it is
you don't have to worry you don't have
to worry about either one of them
wrestling it's a great fight yeah
no it's it's got a lot of intrigue
that fight's fun you have the pearls on
i don't know about those i guess pearls
are making come back a little bit that's
the one
yeah it's not my thing it's cool but
it's like it's a little much i think
yeah a little feminine for your chin no
a little bit too feminine just not does
that's not it doesn't look like it fits
i mean when i was a kid nobody's wearing
pearls whatever you get
little kid's attention these days it's
like oh good that's what he's going for
it's also just like different you know
yeah i get it pearls are cool from the
sea
clams
from the oysters oysters oysters that's
right
you know i'm talking about yeah
that place is packed he's an islander
yeah i hope this one doesn't go to
decision to be honest with you fellas
it just goes decision and unless it's a
great fight but if it goes decision i
don't see it being a great fight i see
izzy just light him up from the outside
cannon not really taking chances and we
get a boring fight doing what he did
with polycast and what he did with some
of the other guys like victoria but
paulo and a lot of those guys didn't
take really chances that's why they
[ __ ] up but then whitaker didn't get
starched they they didn't take chances
because izzy's stand up because that's
what i'm saying yeah
just brought it back yeah but uh vitoria
was saying he goes it's tough because
he's lost him twice right but tori's
like he there's so much like smoke
that i didn't realize what was going on
in the fight like he throws all this
[ __ ] and by the time i figure out he's
out man has he fought since he lost a
yawn
yeah victoria's default whitaker right
yeah
okay not gonna be able to beat him he's
gonna have this
izzy's a tough matchup for that tory's
just mean potatoes he's got no intention
he's gonna work with no he's fought
twice he's the hardest he fought for
because he's a hard worker and he gets
better every fight that's what i [ __ ]
with
so many fights
they all just messed up together now man
trust me i know between watching like
pfl wait what are you saying ufc there's
memorize all the fights memories
remember i was like i was like man i
said as easy fast as he fought since he
lost the yard yeah
they just all meshed together and you
watched so many fights like see but i
think if uh izzy smokes cannon there
let's say we're smoke canada and then he
fights pierre destroys pierre i think he
fights at 205 because he should if
yuri's the champ it's a much better
matchup than yon oh yeah he needs a
striker like you're one of those striker
those [ __ ] european polish strikers
though but here's the thing though yuri
really impressed me when he was in the
top position not on the bottom but when
he got on top of glover i was like holy
[ __ ]
heavy i was like wow yeah he did some
good work i'm surprised he didn't try to
get a couple more takedowns from that
position or at least try to get you know
every time glover sat back to his back
i'm surprised he didn't try to jump on
top and do more because i think uh izzy
can be successful at 205. just yan was
the worst matchup yeah well i wouldn't
say you want to grapple he's just too
big i think he can't just jump up he's
got to spend the time to get his body up
there though yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
johnny's massive yeah he cuts from 240.
he's thick and he can grapple so for
izzy he was just nightmare now yuri
ain't gonna grapple
and i think technically izzy's a better
striker
not more powerful but he's a better
striker that's a guy i haven't seen a
long time robert rob emerson yeah wc
days dude and ultimate fight yeah i was
supposed to fight him a couple of times
we never did fight but i was supposed to
fight him a couple times he's a head tap
now yeah that's crazy man man when you
lay down and you're thinking about
getting your head out you should
probably rethink it
it's just the people just think a little
bit longer about it just depends what
profession like i'd love a face tap man
neck tap face tat i see i've always kind
of wanted a nice neck one so bad i want
a neck one but i'm like nah
all my boys have like do you have
attached them no not one no you don't
put it you wanted to go on a bentley bro
come on luke luke you don't have any
cats either right
no i guess we'll count that
what is the first date with davey lovato
no jesus
dude i'd get a tattoo with her as myself
you're a model dog hell yeah cool for
the summer that summer body she's
singing here and [ __ ]
love it man
quite the life my man
surfing and [ __ ] in your off time i
don't serve anymore you stop surfing
stop surfing surfing's annoying
wow
negative nancy where'd you come from
crowded space full of a bunch of people
that don't know what they're doing yeah
but you can surf them his brother his
brother's pro he's playing was pro oh
it's really really good really yeah did
your brother look like you
uh he looks like a kid rock
yeah
his brother can serve kid rock now or
like trump kid rocks oh [ __ ] look at
this guy look at this guy
oh wow he's doing the undertaker nice
good call you're telling me that weird
guy he might have passed away the weird
guy who'd go you know uh the the [ __ ] uh
taker like
the weird string tell me he couldn't
find him isn't it well i bet that guy's
40 bucks for the night yeah
tell him to take
he's shifting his whole audience to
being a performer you never know what
he's going to do that's why the young
girls now it's like now it's like you're
like you're like what is he gonna do
what's he gonna do next
smart not just about it's smart god i
wish someone could hear it because is he
coming out to undertake your song
i wanna hear it god god damn it damn it
next episode we'll get it done thing
that throws me off is the crypto does he
have contractions too motherfucker's got
contacts in i think crypto i don't know
you're gonna have to take him out though
like dude do you know how gangster this
walkout is especially if you win no
those aren't are they does he have
contacts no it's just the way that it's
flashing around his eyes
yeah it's the way the light's hitting
them dude
is he i like what he's doing though
you take out connor izzy is as far as
like he's got a star he's up there
when he thought where's the first time
i'm gonna come out with that you don't
think i'm up there on that connor stage
i said take conor out okay you said
nobody's calling but who else though who
else in there well as far as like big
names you got nate diaz yeah
patty that's about it
paddy hasn't headlined a pay-per-view
yet but he's still mad yeah he's massive
who else do they have right now that's
think about all the all the like old
heads are the jon jones you know
everyone gives them a knock on his
pay-per-view but you look it up it ain't
bad it's not right though either it
ain't ain't bad though i'm telling you
the ufc paying that narrative which is
not pay-per-view you draw they're full
of [ __ ] dude
you gotta remember though too a lot of
that is because of the streaming these
yeah a lot of the
espn deal that's true because they don't
they don't give a [ __ ] about people yeah
they get their nut no matter what yeah
they gave it away when they did that yep
yeah i said dope ass walking remember we
did the dancing walk out that was that
was awesome you're not feeling itching
no i wish we could hear it that's the
thing yeah yeah me too no one's feeling
that because we can't hear it
i want to feel it yeah it's like isn't
it is it a western theme you know it's
like if you can't hear it is it a cowboy
there's got to be a way to write plug in
the sound into the headset no we could
but we usually you're going to discuss
this already like you can do that it's
gonna like probably like take your just
it'll be a little bit like that's very
true that's very true i could see that
but i thought we thought that guy's in
shape in the back there i thought we
talked about um you having the the
earpiece yeah but then but then but then
we can also criticize the commentary
that's awesome yeah but that's all so
fun put one ear in both yeah the only
problem is if we had one earring
listening then we could stop talking
exactly the audience like hey dude yeah
that's true but then we could like i
said if we could hear what the
commentary is saying about like you know
yeah there could be there could be some
places
but really ching could just tell us like
hey he's coming out the undertaker hey
rogan's next one for sure logan said max
hall is up four to one
he looks good
one person yeah
no it should be you or casey because i
should be able to go to casey like hey
what's happening right here he's like yo
they think you know working on it
we'll do it next episode
there's manscape popping back up promo
code cfc
landscape everywhere dude
you must have it
so griffin's saying it was the
undertaker
i mean yeah you can't come out without
dude unless you come out like that here
i'm just pitching izzy on his next
walkout you come in same attire come out
to the yellow stone anthem kevin
costner's in your corner dude
beth from yellowstone redhead english
whatever she's dressed like a cowboy
he's pissing off
he's marking it he marked his territory
on the cage he is a savage he is an
entertainer you just have oh [ __ ] and
he's dancing
boy he's big he's tall his reach looks
like you saw when you saw them face to
face with the wings like how's that
cigar daddy that was great dude perfect
timing did you started just now we're
about nice now he did walk out like the
undertaker though with the hat and the
the urine
really yes you missed that put it back
dude and we turned it we blasted it like
the music was nuts damn and then the ac
was blaring where you're going you guys
had ac in here
you left ac turned on
volume was insane believe it or not the
reach is not that much of a difference i
mean i know it's
like earth [ __ ] that's the vibe we're
getting because he did have on like some
earthy yeah he's very jewels oh he's
watching the ghillie suit
he thinks crystals give him energy hell
yeah you think bruce buffer could throw
a good right hook
bruce bob first had you had some fights
he's fought frank trigg in the elevator
bruce buffery's fight yes
about frank trigg in an elevator
a lot of people gave him business why
not what i heard oh no
yeah
and the only people that know are rogan
frank trigg and bruce wow and everybody
listening how did that all come about i
don't know i don't know what happened
wow a boy
dean herb dean dean he's back they saved
him for the birthday he likes to fall
huh
oh no
that's the knock on him yeah is that uh
what are they called right titty sags a
little bit still yeah still
what do you think that's from there
some people say it could be from weed
i call it weed tit weed i just made that
up i don't know
but i think it affects your eyes more
than your tits yeah you're right
he likes to [ __ ] see it's got a
little something how long do you think
you'd last against style better me
versus izzy i would just grapple him
it'd be a boring decision boring
decision yeah he beat me for sure right
okay but it'd be boring
but that guy is jack now he used to
fight that heavyweight the heavyweight
205. now he's down to 85. savage who's
the biggest size fighter
well they're all within the weight class
but i'm saying like like wait biggest
size oh i would say i don't know how
this [ __ ] sport works the biggest size
fighter i love that statement to his
point though probably uh rumble johnson
when he's fighting yeah
well i would say probably maybe khabib
fits in there too those guys come in
what i'm saying who was the biggest one
let me see a photo
240.
rumble came in to train with us 10 years
ago back at aka and he was 2 20.
fighting at 170. yeah i came in i was
like look in this dude i was like nuts
yeah it's like
this part of the scene so gleeson taobao
was huge oh yeah i mean dude
uh gleason yeah gleason tebow yeah
how big was that that's what i'm saying
like who
cut down like look at the fight him
right there for sure yeah he was nuts
same guy got a heavyweight fight or lost
that looks like a before and after of
cocaine yeah but flipped no the left
looks like intervention the right looks
like thick boy summer there it is
what's up
josh how big uh did khabib walk when
he's competing
sometimes he'd come to camp around 190
195. i didn't know he's that big yeah
but i mean within two weeks he'd get it
down like islam is just he's a tall like
with khabib he's short stocky thick ass
he likes to eat more islam is more
taller and stretched out but [ __ ] he's
probably the strongest guy i think i've
ever grappled with he's so scared
right now though i just saw the video
down
he's big he's dry he's but he's big but
now i'm talking about like in terms of
strength wise like islam still got to
keep his weight down luke how's that
going you and khabib grapple
[Laughter]
he's so good though he's strong strong
he's a lot stronger now he's technical
too in a lot of his positioning
heavy on the hip sit you to your butt
dude how about your boy kane give him
[ __ ] bail yeah i know
that's the least of his worries right
now my man yeah you know what i'm saying
that gold jacket bringing more attention
to it they're not they're not they're
not touching them
and bring more pressure you know i mean
like we're supposed to have a stand-in
the only thing you're talking about
you're talking about the government but
the government's just [ __ ] up man
they're letting pedophiles out it's just
that's a whole conversation well
especially in california but that's also
why the the d.a got recalled in san
francisco stupid man
but kane's suing the uh the pedophile
yeah yep no i mean like
for them to release this guy back to the
nuts it's just like the guy committed
his crimes on the on the premises of a
daycare where he lives and you released
him back to that great character and
multiple kids where he's been
multiplying you released him back to his
praying ground but then you won't like
government you want
no bail yes they allowed this man that's
crazy a 40 sick
living on the premises of a daycare
level
it was the biggest story though it's
craziest i think the government could
allow this guy i would have done the
whole but here's my thing we've done
everything in more candles every man i
would have done with kane yeah i got
kids maybe he's smarter maybe just a
smarter way there's definitely a smarter
way to do it wouldn't hurt also he's got
a dog on the left moment of rage as well
for kane
the moment they released this guy i
would have lost my mind if i'm kingdoms
they didn't even tell them
you're gonna kill them with your hands a
little you know he's a little out there
these days
but um i mean he's a good man and he
tried to do the right thing you know
well how old is kane healthcare he's
he's
got 38 38 38. so
39 so for
for 38 years and 11 months and three
weeks
he's been a great human being of a
[ __ ] oh except for one kid that
threatened his child's life
in his livelihood in this future you're
talking about molesting yeah i mean
that's what i'm saying threaten that's a
that's a life-threatening issue here's
the thing luke [ __ ] bail all that stuff
it's gonna go to a jury and a jury's
gonna side with cain again i don't think
so oh i disagree not in california not
well he's reckless well they can't pick
that he's reckless for like the
endangerment of the world yeah but if
you have parents in that jury not one
parent's gonna be like ah i disagree
because every parent knows the rage if
you [ __ ] with their kids i get it but
they're also gonna be like oh you shot
the wrong person i don't like guys
attitude yeah i want kane i want candy i
wanna don't sound like it fellas i think
we should get our own boxing match here
huh yeah
fired up dude
i just hate the world
yeah
but i also read that uh the guy the
father that was involved the other that
was involved they knew that their got
their strength yes was molested yeah and
stuff yeah yes
so that means and that's why you really
shoot the wrong person he shot something
exactly
they're all guilty
that whole family needs to be guilty
i don't know what's going on still
operate
i'm sure is that something to operate
like how who in the world that's his
code but then california's gonna shut
trevor don't know what's going on so
this kane velasquez who's their training
partner really close friend i know who
he is yeah so he was the world champion
heavyweight world champion yeah his kid
was in a daycare and got molested a
four-year-old they that guy uh got uh
bail kane found out he was released and
then chased the guy and his dad who also
knew that his son was less than uh
children and chased him down the car and
shot at the car and hit the dad and then
got arrested and they won't post bail
for and he's looking at at minimum of 15
years for attempting this yes
did he did he kill the guy or just shot
him shut the dash i'm like got the dad
it like grazed him like in the hip kind
of harboring this guy and like
operating a daycare it's the sickest
well this is the thing is i've been down
i've been to almost every one of their
core things and that the reason is he's
the threat to society i'm like no he's a
threat to one person correct he would
never chase anyone else down he has
never chased anyone down again 38 years
yeah 11 months
wow six days
you know you
three minutes and you're you're gonna
you're gonna label him what a threat to
society when he's been a model citizen
his entire life
is this recent yes yes jesus yeah and
they just they don't see california
doesn't see pedophiles as violent
criminals and so which is crazy they
don't trust the charge the long-term
effect of that they don't come with
pedophiles they don't convict any
pedophiles they just set them on a
background
it's [ __ ] sick the whole government
switches
look how relaxed is kenny you're looking
good though
yeah but is he gonna is he a little more
if he'll find his uh timing
just like he's just he's like a strong
strickland kind of fighter you know he's
so dumb and just on
forward pressing
you know he doesn't he's not going to
bring like a [ __ ] like a very
intellectual
dynamic fight but he's going to come
with everything he has and he's very
strong so close first round trouble
close first round
i'm going to probably give it to you
he's usually feeling out he usually
feels people a little bit like that
anderson silva anderson takes about two
and a half three minutes to fill you out
yeah then he starts adjustment is what
makes champions yeah adjustment is he's
gonna be anyway in any sport that's how
champions are made
rob went in on the head tattoo oh he's
all in jason
that's crazy
i don't think i could do it ever
had that no yeah i mean unless i if i
was like elon musk rich i'd get my
entire face i'd look like post malone
i'm sick
grow my hair out girl you would oh
my i'd have my nose pierced
i couldn't do it man i'd have a muscle
in the back i'd have my nose anybody
made fun of me i just haven't beat you
up did you get a chance
trust
like
beat them up
it's a hitman i believe they call it
i've always wanted to do a full sleeve
but like one that kind of caters into my
back of my hand a little bit and then
one that kind of trickles up into my
neck oh yeah but i'm too much of a
blessing i can younger my man not too
much of a [ __ ] to lay down for
12 15 hours and they take forever yeah
i'm one of those guys i had a dream
getting an arm sleep
yeah right
i just i just i can't lay down in there
yeah a big finish from izzy would be
fantastic for the ufc
beats pierre all day nine times out of
ten he beats unless he gets caught you
think so yes dude styles make matchups
yeah always make match-ups man
what's going on
is he just got some on his back foot
surprise canter hasn't even attempted a
shot yet
especially after watching he's just
mesmerized with it
that's what vittorio is saying he's like
there's a lot of smoke man you think one
thing and then this is what he does he's
beautiful look at it he's he's [ __ ]
with him right now he doesn't know he
doesn't know how to calculate it
you gotta [ __ ] bring it
isn't it interesting though for izzy's
body kick a body kick isn't meaningful
when you hit a southpaw with a body kick
because it's so hard to
just dig in it's not the meaning that
that when you hit an orthodox guy
because the liver is there and then yeah
susceptibility is different i it's so
interesting as izzy right you're he's
going from a cannon there fight if he
wins this to uh you know
yeah i know
kickbox it's so different i mean night
and day
have you liked the crown
yeah like canyoneer just looks lost oh i
think izzy's gonna
looks like he's just like oh guys he
just realized i just
don't
i just don't know again i don't fight or
iq i don't know you wouldn't grapple
more
at least threaten it like you don't have
to get it you just gotta threaten it if
you're just doing a kickboxing match
with it is he my man this ain't
something
so make it dirty not a he's not an
educated grappler he's a man that came
into the sport later from like football
i believe right uh something something
different like he doesn't have a he
doesn't have a history in grappling
he's a he's just a new breed fighter
it's hard if you're not a high level
grappler to shoot in on izzy with the
knees you're not if you're not grappling
at birth i mean like
to attack a guy
oh he hit him there
that's a little right check hook
when he's offensive when ken near's
offensive he's doing it
he keeps going backwards i think he's he
is a counter puncher though it's trouble
he just needs him to commit and he's
gonna get finished
oh that was nice it's a little head kick
there is he looks so focused man look at
his eyes his eyes he looks in there like
relaxed hungry like he's going to get a
finish i agree cannon is like look at
look at that cannon in here's eyes and
look at izzy's eyes yep canada is a cat
it's like a panic yeah he's a panic you
can see the [ __ ] he can't figure it
out is he's just dialed in he's starting
to get his assessment
i mean i can't tell if pierre is just
the [ __ ] ultimate badass or if it was
just a strickland stupid
fighting style
he's still a badass
yeah you know what i'm saying though is
he that [ __ ] good or is it just
strickland oh nice
oh oh that didn't touch though
i bet you candidates gonna take more
chances in the third and fourth oh wow
you don't see them see this yeah that
was nice
yeah take izzy down's gonna take a look
hey let's just stick to the punching
buddy yeah that's uh it sucks
his thought process was like oh i'm
gonna do it no i'm not gonna do it
but i think everyone is a better round
for his eyes yeah
he's still losing though he is i think
but i think people watch the yawn fight
like oh we can take izzy down it's a lot
no tougher than you fake
young's just massive
oof
filthy combo
yeah fizzy starts letting loose man he's
gonna get a finish
he will it takes about three hours nice
little checkout takes about like these
kind of fights
that's why i said third or fourth that
landed second
yeah he's gonna finish in the third
fourth yeah there's no way canada gets
the past fourth
white book in the eye pokes in the eye
you think that izzy jon jones fight ever
comes to fruition nope
john's gonna be a heavyweight is gonna
go to 205. yeah it's gonna be too much
yeah it'll never happen there's too much
wrestling
that's true as well
john johnson john can wrestle he already
figured out he's like going up to you
know so john took dc going up the guy
i'm too big ac down for godzilla
wrestle man can [ __ ] wrestle juco
national champ you know no punk
it just comes from a lineage of
good genetics dude his brothers him like
think about that freaking crazy you got
two brothers in the [ __ ] nfl yeah i
mean you one's all pro yeah yeah
yeah but john's mind is different than
those kids those kids are just
they're the great athletes jones like
the champion mentality yes his mentality
is nutsos
it's a mentality man that's what they've
got there's too much this isn't only
against you so far fighting is great
and then when you kiss it's not like
you're born of this so it's like oh
you're this like [ __ ]
try to devour your headspace trying to
go into a fight agree a championship
level fight but then you get the the the
real special guys that have that
athletic ability with that mentality
then you're talking about it's the
craziest headspace in the world when you
have two the two best fighters in the
world on each side of the planet meeting
is the exact point in time everything
you do in your life to that point
nothing perfect nothing better you know
it's like
you're just sitting there it's the
craziest concept in the world
there's nothing like it uh dana came out
to the it's either going to be in ghana
or it's going to be stipe for john first
i think he'll do steve bailey i think so
too yeah i think in ghana they're not
going to pay for the money he wants and
he's the fury fight's there for him so
you can get steep age on yeah just
builds the hype of that fight too if he
beats deep in correct cool it i mean you
can mark can get you can demand any
money you want
and
they'll
diminish oh look at the [ __ ] [ __ ]
cannon there's definitely was that this
third second second i predicted third or
fourth ko
can't hear just got to be pressing is he
backwards he's got to walk him down
throw shots
right now he's getting pushed around the
cage a little bit here and there
it's that that reaches his eyes shutting
to his eyeballs one of those eyes is
shutting for him because he oh good body
shot
pink oh right there yeah those are the
worst man how are you that knuckle hits
you right in the eye and the eye socket
you're like ugh he's still looking all
right though he's not that done
rob emerson's head is intense that's
insane
yeah hell's angel you could have already
gave himself a hairline he could have
gave it a little bit more forward though
right why'd you do it so far back it
looks like he was just losing his hair
was it
there's a new
it looks
no i'm surprised they don't dry these
guys off
oh yeah
i could have handed you something you're
looking for
we got some white claws diet cokes
miller light rain
oh
here comes izzy yeah i think izzy gets
to finish it here here he comes
canada just looks like he's just like
there's not
enough thought process behind what he's
doing
but if you look at the different the
difference between pereira and him in
terms of relaxation right now on the
feet yeah prayer looks so much more
relaxed oh yeah and
but yeah but i have it's precision man
it's creativity too it's like what would
he but israel does different
yeah that's such a damn so into that
matchup
right before i do
does easy wrestle
who's your toughest matchup luke is he
i don't think so who do you think's
toughest
um
i don't know
i mean i would say i probably i mean
like i said if it was previously
it would have been costa had it been the
previous
now it's easier now i mean but
a prime romero i was i was a weak i was
weak in and like i i want romero in a
different state would be different
i see how to fight romero i didn't see
it the first time
plus he felt like he was just doing some
[ __ ] good [ __ ]
i've never felt anybody like that
someone said whose eggs were like cement
whittaker said the same [ __ ] like every
time i kicked him i told him i told
whitaker i told what occurred before the
fight when he was going back in i was
like listen dude this guy is like
there's something going on
on his legs and like be careful his legs
i was like tell him whitaker watch out
like
i'll tell you what gets me rock hard
beside your only fans is you versus
whittaker that's a fun i mean i really
thought you're about to go into a
bluetooth i thought you were
i was like
who else gets me hard blue chips
yeah i know i i like the whitaker
fighting and that was not supposed to
fight whitaker and then you will came
you don't miss wait and that is the poll
you must be doing work with blue chew
that's like well we work with them yeah
oh yeah our podcast does i think
whitaker you know what whittaker is my
toughest fight whitaker is definitely
harder i was going with that my man
100 because he's so agile man he's hard
to track down around the corner
he's by far he's wrestle and he's good
on time by far my hardest fight by far i
think your jiu jitsu is
a different dynamic there for him but
his wrestling's really wrestling has
gotten a lot better yeah he's tracking
him that's like getting him in the you
know
i blast him on the outside with kicks
you know just like i think he'd have to
get through that process
oh he's striking some too much kendra's
just got to let it go he's holding back
i mean yeah it's either that or you just
get lit up but then you take those
chances when you get knocked out gonna
happen but honestly for him to win this
fight you just gotta make it dirty man
you gotta say [ __ ] it you gotta make it
caution the wind
does that's all he does though
he's a dirty fighter man he's just but
is he's doing a great job not letting
that he's not even like
the one champion against champions man
they make you question everything
look at him that jab's gonna be a
problem
you know what i love about his jab he
doesn't turn it over it's like that's
like a shovel jab yeah i mean that's the
same jab where it's like the elbows stay
tight
it's a really beautiful shot
yeah look at it and he does it every
time it's there's no tail to it like
that he's also so dynamic from
traditional to south palm beach there's
no tell it's it's very
jared just got to throw man you got to
oh that like oh gotta throw those israel
throws
he's always thrown when you think he's
not throwing any stone
that's where he hits you
i mean really uh k9 has only attempted
two takedowns
well did you just see that's a nice
right hand
that one was we both looked ahead to
look at each other the one time it was
so bad he had a better didn't even
really he just thought about it it was
like a brain fart that he thought about
it now double unders now yeah
if you remember jan got him down with
this but different animal at the
middleweight things that's so easy
yawn's as tall as busy
like his neck is like
yeah
he said polish power he's so [ __ ]
yeah crazy he's weird he's a weird human
you think john beats uh yuri
i don't know man is he easy next yeah i
think that fight could go either way
just soon
it all depends on how yuri fights i
think yeah that's why it's pretty good
off how yuri fights because even here it
was like that last fight against glover
he's like i didn't want to fight like
that like that was not my best fight man
that was a nightmare i think clover had
nothing
20 seconds from not being your fight
yeah yeah no no that would it was just a
brawl and he was like i did not want
that fun yeah cool it was fun for fans
but for years he's like that's the way
yuri fights though but that's okay
sometimes he creates that he's chaos
yeah
it's weird even glow but jerry going for
that choke
so you're gonna choke out a black belt
with a head arm triangle dude what are
you doing yeah yeah the [ __ ] you doing
i mean a lot of mistakes at that high
level at that high level i thought they
both had off nights that's what made for
a good fight but both had off nights but
just like simple things when you have
him mounted and you let his feet against
the fence we can just roll out kick
through i'm like what do you think
him away from the face
exactly you know what i'm saying i'm
like walk him away from your head don't
let him don't let him know the fence and
he just kept every time he had the
takedown he'd let him get let him use
his feet against the fence i'm like damn
what are you doing
threatening that take down when you
didn't would not take down threatening
submission when you didn't need one so
just stay where you're at you're in
mouth fights clover house too dude nuts
right you're just like i said what are
you doing championship fights for a
reason man yep [ __ ] happens yeah it
brings out it's fun for the fans
everyone's like that's the greatest
lightning heavyweight five of all time
like you ever seen jon jones gus's thing
no the highest level you could say it's
entertaining can't say it's not great it
was entertaining but it was entertaining
because there were so many mistakes
correct
yeah
even john dc's phenomenal fights yeah dc
gusman's phenomenal fights
that first sunglasses
my dream fight and for me for a goat
pound-for-pound heavyweight goat of all
time is a prime cane versus a prime
steepest yeah that's the to number one
who's the best of all time canvas prime
magano would be [ __ ] crazy i think i
think wears them
i've trained with
everybody in the gym i'm such an animal
and kane just came just to being that i
just never like ever wanted to like even
in his prime i've seen him on so many
levels and i've been i've sparred
francis i support everybody yeah pope
francis and kane wanted keynes is a
different demon yeah
kane is a different demon than anybody
i've ever [ __ ] in his prime there was
nothing that's why i think
prime cain beats any heavyweight on the
planet ever nothing like him he beats
fedor
before his girl came
oh
yeah even like the beginning of her
before like he was softened by his
daughter yeah he was the freaking nasty
what scared what scared me about like a
prime like fedor was that kane's
weakness was always kind of the
submissions because he no one could ever
take him down and so that would be it my
thing was kane's pressure and then not
so at the faders you have a hard time
getting him down kane would destroy
foreign kane and with his cardio too
you've never seen carter like that
heavily ever close one with stipe but i
don't think you'd match i like that dude
not at that pace there's no there's no
off switch no
i mean he's the best of all time every
time i'd spar him i have to be like
[ __ ] i'd have javier be able to pull
the rip cord because i could only hang
with him i do good for like a round but
he's just the price i started hitting
him a little bit and the pressure was
just the levels from striking to
punching to wrestling and the more you
hit him there was just like more
pressure there was so many levels he
couldn't counteract what he was doing ah
that's not looking good it would just it
would build maybe even dc told me he's
like dude i'm telling you you've never
seen nothing anything
phenomenal yeah no he's my number one
kane is
yeah one of the most amazing fighters of
all time
a goat truly one of the ghosts he was
just playing by injuries
top five goat top five good hard 100
percent yeah oh yeah it's so hard
maybe top three he's my number one
heavyweight he might be the number one
heavyweight like bad oh he's probably
never ever just style this guy just
don't technique and like what francis
is bad no frank keynes kane was like
flawless everywhere i saw it steep aid
like a prime steve babers you know
but francis has got a lot better since
that ebay fight but kane just came
john's interesting i i just john's such
a savage dude i just don't know how
steep no i don't think so i heard sea
bass got really lean he's put on 10
pounds of muscle yeah probably that's
good for him though
i thought he looked good against when he
fought dc that was putting on it because
he looked like
he looked too lean last time yeah
apparently he's put on uh 10 pounds of
muscle so it looks like he's bigger yeah
he needs to be bigger
maybe he's like his long hair does that
[ __ ] his the longer you're in the skinny
look last time he just looked frail and
there's no like bounce he wasn't like
balanced and focused well my only worry
on john is he's getting too big when he
told me he's like two six i'm like
what's he doing
but he'll lean out he gets into a real
camp though yeah he'll lean out he's
getting into a calm down he's putting
the weight on but then as he gets into a
real camp he'll start to lean out yeah
if john's serious about having out i
don't know who beats him
i think he wants to take everything once
once he gets into a full 10-week
campaign
i think he'll end up i think he'll end
up getting down to probably like 245
somewhere around there big dude that's a
big guy
who are we kidding he's probably walking
around around 230 normally for sure so
putting on 15 pounds not a big deal you
know but it's also he's not like a
knockout artist even if he puts on that
weight so
he'll take guys down you know but he
he'll do it where it's north south
that little foot sweep he does little
things that break your balance catch the
leg also his volume but my only thing
with that is like with volume you're not
going to do it against francis well the
guy's
francis lands one bomb if you look at
the guys that jon jones had problems
with is people that are long tall long
and lanky guys that match his heavy was
reach which
which is heavyweight so those guys
yeah those guys are going to start to
get a little bit of a problem
it's just if francis lands one
heavyweight
every week but francis is a different
being
francis is just
like it's a dangerous fight it's just
that francis can land i don't know if we
see it to be honest and unless ufc puts
up the the money francis wants because
he can go make all the money with
fury you know yeah yeah
which also if i'm france oh my god
i think you're he's crazy enough he'll
do it no yeah yeah yeah yeah fury's in
oh he's in yeah i love him he knows
that's a lot of money here he's just a
great human being
but what does this say though if like
like in this fight right
should he have lost or should not lost
but it should shouldn't he have finished
him
you would help yeah he still has another
round to do it yeah riker did
right
where he could put
trevor's just checked out yeah i'm just
trying to say what's going on inside
baseball
take mcgregor out of it um
probably brandon shop no i mean like
yeah
no but as far as but like just like
you know
fighters yeah active fighters like clout
and just like just guys i would say
dubai money yeah you could you could buy
money yeah
so what is the score going
to say brock no you got you got to
retire khabib's retired keep going
horny gracie will be acting and [ __ ]
right that's gsp
yeah
i would assume yeah three to four mil
yeah right i already got a good contract
you think so i think he's getting
probably about two i don't think he's
getting three to five i heard he got
assigned a [ __ ] contract so he's got
to be at least i would think three to
five he's a big star that list is so old
chin please no it's just it's just 20
22. that's insane but it's bad yeah
they're getting a genius decide on what
is real you say active fighters type in
active who's highest paid active fighter
stupid though
i'll tell you who makes more money than
all the ufc fighters put together is
jake paul hey
how do we know why we know what what
canelo makes why do we know what [ __ ]
lebron makes why do we know what's
happening because he's in the top and we
don't know what people make on a fighter
yeah
this is old chicken yeah there you go i
mean current fighters you'd have to
assume
uh let me think you got uh pouring uh
nate diaz um fighting enough nate
all's making a lot of money i'd say it
ain't nothing mozzarella's making more
money probably more
i know colby doesn't want to take a
fight until he makes as much as mozville
that's what he's saying he's like i beat
that dude and you're paying more than me
and he's like well yeah
when's dustin fighting again
he's kind of just chilling he wants to
fight nate um
crazy that ain't gonna happen no i would
like to see that fight going back to me
why wouldn't that happen just different
ways on his last fight of his contract
and they don't want to potentially have
nate win
so if nate does beat him now i have a
fighter that like we have a lot of money
in there they were going to toss hamza
tonight it's like what the [ __ ] yeah but
then harm's not turning
on they're gonna talk nate down i guess
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
you mean feed them to him
delicious
he's such a bad match every night
but they're supposed to uh colby hans
out on abc
that's what they're trying to do but
colby wants moz with all money
if it's on abc maybe
maybe you can make that money oh they're
kind of throwing them now
uc is the best sport but also the worst
when it's boring yeah like even football
i'm like i had to run a lot i understand
you know but sometimes i'm not saying
this is bad i'm just saying when they're
but when ufc is boring it is a tough
sell yeah
the only sport worse when it's slow is
boxing this card on paper looks so much
better than him the fights have been
shutting out good i mean i you know i
guess volcanosi kind of won by a
landslide just one by landslide this
fight was won by landslides the fight
was dope lawler was a great fighter
follower was fine but then sugar got
high poke yeah right you're like
right that's how these go and then those
fight nights where you're like oh i
don't know any of these guys it's like
the best fighter bar burners
john and i on on our show we always talk
about just sleeper good fights like
these are this is this is one of those
sleeper fights that's why you can't say
oh this is a [ __ ] card because no
no something you never know man some of
those sleeper cards it's a fire because
those younger guys man they come out and
those are hungry guys also they come out
they're hungry they want to show out
make a name for themselves yeah it's
their one time to get on tv
you know i remember a fight couple years
ago backspin kick knocked him out first
round like 10 seconds you guys know what
that is by chance
it might have been bar
barboza and elkins
that was a long time ago it was a while
ago
oh that's right what does it mean oh
buckley it was [ __ ] buckled kanye
west retweeted it oh it was great but
that was when i was got everybody going
see he only knows that one yeah you know
dustin poirier because he beat connor in
that big highlight yeah
mostly guys i know because knowledge of
his like what he computes is like you
see like sugar shawn you know oh yeah
it's that whoever
if theo has him on the podcast but oh
that dude yeah yeah
but that but to be honest like unless
you're hardcore that's most people do
yeah i'm saying like that's why they
want those crops over that's why you get
into the crossover
yeah
oh he's trying to finish him now
yep 50 seconds
needs to let it go oh
oh [ __ ]
kendra's a tough [ __ ] dude though man
didn't he you just gotta throw man let
it go yeah you take more chances you got
nothing to lose in 40 seconds
at the end of the day it's still an l
next to your name wait what's those
what's the odds are gonna be on the
pierre fight versus busy after this oh
come on throw it's so hard to knock
because i was gotta fight this level
dude i mean after the end of the fight
you just so well oh yeah
you're like a romantic only thing with
the piano shots the pierre fight and
strickland like you don't think izzy
would knock stricken enough if you
thought is he like that yeah of course
he would of course so it's it's hard to
gauge right here that's why it's so
interesting
well you know that neither one of them
gonna try to take each other down and
then remember they fought when they
fought kickboxing those were those
pillow gloves yeah hot seconds yeah
you're wearing you're wearing 10 ounce
gloves it's a big difference when you're
blocking punches and is he he doesn't
get hit unless he wants to like you the
kelvin gaslum fight [ __ ] like that i
just that fight's so interesting
49-46 you you had you had uh homeboy win
in one round cannon
yeah i was like i didn't know where that
happened yeah i don't know where you'd
give him the round
yeah man the co and the main were kind
of smooth sailing there's no finishes
anytime there's no finishes it's like it
just is not as memorable of the night
and especially when it's not like the
fight of the night ooh that was a thick
kick that was a thick bookcase that's
nasty boom that was the elbow though too
i caught the elbow
oh
just all izzy highlights
you notice how he doesn't load up a lot
of this [ __ ] he's just [ __ ] it's all
just
touch touch touch there's no actual like
you know yeah i i gotta be honest i
thought kendra would maybe grapple try
and grab a little more i know he's not
his background but [ __ ] dude
was it like a big underdog in this yeah
he was like what plus six hundred plus
six figures so that's kind of a dub for
him to go five rounds no yeah yeah
cost me a hundred bucks though yeah it's
never put a hundred now it's never a
dollar let's just see
the belt and the money in the in the
wind bonus and also if you didn't really
win a round because ufc if izzy's champ
you'd never get that title shot it's a
big difference between winning and
losing and fighting oh the biggest it's
a big [ __ ] half your paycheck it's a
big difference the momentum to your next
fight
the momentum especially a title like
like winning a fight is like it's
it could be millions of dollars or it
could be like a couple hundred
yeah and that's remember like one fight
one finale the people because the
endorsements are so low the endorsements
and
potential for like negotiations for your
next fight you know what the winning
fight is everything it's like because
i've seen it's not just wins and not one
bonus and not two but also if you're
ever at cantonese level so he's running
whatever two or one there
you lose to izzy you're not like you're
fighting number at nine or ten yeah the
next day you're fighting like three or
four yeah the [ __ ] nightmare but i've
seen i was thinking
kenneth had no marketability and he said
this was like this is a win for him like
because no one thought he was capable of
doing it 45 now he's more marketable
i've seen i've seen champs though what
is this you don't know plane
it's like a movie right yeah theaters
prime spot right there i've seen i've
seen champions get on the plane first
class then they lose their title come
home first class then you see them next
time on the plane they're looking coach
southwest yes all the way in the back
south they're boarding they're like
they're boarding oh yeah south west
check in early enough
yeah you're like oh wait you're like
what they're like the championship
clause i'm like no
nope
not getting on that flight well the
biggest thing would um we have the same
manager me and stephen struve i mean he
flies first right like no they won't pay
for it he's seven foot tall though
he's in the real
marketing i'm like but he flies from the
travel team he flies from amsterdam i
don't deal with the travel team i don't
deal with the travel team yeah
that nuts stephanie's true seven foot
tall dude
i would oh obviously he's gonna call out
pierrot
i wonder what this like the whole suits
what's that all behind that well he wore
for the comedy show he got him in all
his guys suit so he probably just wore
the same suit
but you got a good fit man yeah he
doesn't run back it's classy i feel like
he needs to pull the cuff back a little
bit he reminds me of the watch though it
reminds me of uh who's the guy that he
always has on uh lex
like
yeah because he always wears a suit
right it's always like a black and white
one too
i think they need to ease up maybe a
little august mcgregor next time yeah
maybe a little ralph lauren does oh [ __ ]
there he is they'll see he's trying to
translate for right there's this big ass
corner man jesus he's almost the size of
the year he's not trying to [ __ ] buy
a
suit
for that for him jesus nope he ain't
wearing a tie that guy never wearing i'm
shopping at big and tall my man
is he's out of here man wow yeah to your
point josh i mean i thought there's
gonna be fireworks there's more a lot of
mismatches so that you know this is
parents
i think you're stylistically right it's
not looking like his outfit's lit
looking like
i feel like if he's
almost looking like a boxing ring in
there they're just bringing everybody in
yeah what are the dynamic like how do
they choose who comes into a fight after
a boxer you know what i mean like oh
boxing like who gets in the room like
everybody who dictates
everyone
made it
nice to addy like what is that dude
who's that guy
that guy with a fresh haircut that's his
coach there so who are the best fighter
of the night
oh
dos angelos foreign
ortega rodriguez great fight nights
blades aspenal's a fun one
this aspinall kid is is legit he's got
[ __ ] but that's what i was going to say
i thought how he deals with the wrestler
either englishman versus a wrestling see
i would have done aspinol versus um
no no no no i've done cyril gone blades
and then uh aspinal versus uh what's our
boy's name chin from tattoo awesome
that's a fight two of us asked if titus
lose no he won he beat uh lewis that's
right and that's why that's why he's
fighting [ __ ] serial gun dude
versus aspinall would be a good fight
that's what i wanted that's a sexy fight
i like that is that a chin that's it
that's it sorry
we're better kiddos
but thank you guys for coming luke i
know you're in the middle of camp dude
and you're running miles came a little
late we still love you
you spilled the salt your girl's gonna
be so pissed
she spilled the salt all over his
stomach it's like custom salt you know
is it
uh josh thompson weighing podcast dude
we're going to drop on monday morning so
because we're here tonight so we
normally film here tonight so we're
going to drop we'll film tomorrow night
drop monday morning first thing in the
morning fourth of july so you guys get
up early before everyone gets started
drinking you guys can listen to it nice
weighing in on youtube love it one of my
favorite shows trevor walsh
trevor walsh i'm on tour check them out
hawaii july 29th irvine i didn't plug it
once this show july 22nd through the
23rd
and then oh vegas i'm going to be vegas
at the [ __ ] mirage august
august 27th no san jose show uh working
on it good luck working on it big boy
moose trying to manchester bring the
crew out man ask him
yes yeah he'll fight in the crowd for
you oh that'd be awesome be more
exciting than that main event um no i'm
not just kidding
speaking of san jose what do we got we
got dc what's it what's this all about
uh oh dc on the whole for the hall of
fame yeah dc got in the hall of fame my
friend gave you a little love in the
post in the post uh interview him and
khabib oh yeah yeah he's like the only
thing that would have made this better
is having luke and kane here you know so
you guys are all champs
go see trevor in vegas in hawaii and i'm
in fort wayne indiana july 14th through
16th that's fort wayne indiana san diego
lab factory downtown heart of san diego
july 21st through the 23rd baltimore uh
is august 4th through the 6th just
announced it's at a theater in chicago
it's the den theater in chicago one
night only august 26th i'm there for the
tough mudder on august 27th so it's one
show only friday night then the next
morning is the tough mudder so you can
sign up for the tough mudder with me and
come the comedy show and then appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
get tickets at thickboy.com or
f-a-t-k-z.com fellas i love you hope you
guys enjoy this fight companion we're
out
you